Is this static?
I'm hearing just in the headphones.
You heard something?
Yeah,
but it's gone now.
I think live and work and we're lying
for happy motherfucking new year.
Remember when we used to think that the
world's going to end?
Well,
I used to think that the world was gonna
end and even have the license plate.
I did a 2012 license plate.
I was convinced I was like those Mayans,
man.
They knew it.
I thought it was a real,
for sure.
The computer thing.
Remember the Y Two k?
Yeah,
I thought that too.
Yeah.
I stayed home for y two k paranoid.
I was to the clock rolled over planes
falling from the sky.
Yeah.
Everybody's worried about the whole grid
shutting down.
Right.
And they wouldn't be able to get it up
for months and people would run out of
food.
I was listening to art bell a lot back
then.
Oh,
cheers.
Cheers.
[inaudible] New Year.
Happy eight years.
Eight years of episodes.
Eight years of episodes,
2018 2018 doesn't sound like a real
number.
It's one of those numbers.
You say it and you go,
Yup.
I guess I guess you're right like 2018
that's like way too close to 2020 which
is like space.
That's like the future.
It's like a movie you don't like alien.
Like what was,
when you watched the first alien one
with sigourney weaver from the late
seventies it was like 1979 what do you
think the timeline was supposed to be?
It's probably 2001 you know,
cause there's like a lot of movies like
I think blade runner was something like
2017 or something like that.
I want to say,
I don't remember,
but I want to say blade runner was like
2030 or so.
It wasn't that there was all the flying
cars and shit.
Remember weren't there flying cars or am
I thinking of Fifth Element?
No,
no,
there was flying cars.
Cause I remember the car is going
through like the cool billboards and
stuff and I think I confused my Scifi
movies a lot.
Like old ones played renters 2018 2019
oh my God,
that's insane.
That's a year from now.
That's wow.
That's weird.
That shows how slow it actually is.
Technology thinks it's,
you think it's fast.
It shows how bad movie writers are
guessing.
I don't think it shows anything else.
Right.
I think the guy who's been the best at
predicting shit was like wasn't hg wells
really good.
I feel like hg wells,
the science fiction author from,
I think he was from the 18 hundreds hg
wells,
but I think he predicted a lot of shit.
Yeah.
There's a couple articles about all this
stuff you predicted.
Oh really?
Yeah.
The many futuristic predictions of Hg
wells.
It came true.
All right.
Let's see what we got here.
What did he do or 150 years ago,
phones,
email and television.
What is that real in men like gods?
In 1923 wells invites
readers to a futuristic utopia that's
essentially earth.
After thousands of years of progress in
this alternate reality,
people communicate exclusively with
wireless systems that employ a kind of
commingling of voicemail and email like
properties.
Holy Shit,
for an utopia except by previous
arrangement.
People do not talk together on the
telephone.
He writes,
a message is sent to the station of the
district in which the recipient is known
to be.
And there it waits until he chooses to
tap his accumulated messages.
Whoa.
And any that one wishes to repeat can be
repeated.
Then he talks back to the senders in
dispatches.
Any other messages he wishes
the transmission is wireless.
Wow.
What I'd like to know if he did drugs
back then,
like if he was doing mushrooms and yeah,
man,
I want to know.
He also imagined forms of true
entertainment.
Uh,
it says in when the sleeper wakes from
1899,
the protagonist rouses from two
centuries of slumber to a dystopian
London in which citizens used wondrous
forms of technology like the audio book,
Air,
plane,
and television,
yet suffers systematic oppression and
social injustice.
What in the fuck
man,
what the fuck hg wells lasers to?
How's he so good?
It's probably mushrooms.
I mean,
we'll think of something that hasn't
been invented in a hundred years now.
What would you invent like me?
Well,
you know what,
here's our problem.
It's,
I think it's almost impossible once you
know something exists to imagine a world
in which it didn't exist.
So you and I are unique because we're
old as fuck.
I'm older as fucker than you.
But we remember when there was no
internet.
I think we're the last of the people
that are going to remember what life is
like when there's no internet.
Yeah.
And what's next?
What's the thing that hasn't been
invented that we'll remember?
We saw the first stuff like vr.
Good question.
Having glasses always being well I think
that
magic leap shit that you know that
you've seen that new headset that they
uh,
are saying they're going to eventually
wind up selling.
You have like a hip pack and you wear
these goggles.
[inaudible] dude,
that seems like step one to me.
Apple is putting all their money in ar
instead of Vr for that reason.
Right.
That's what this is,
right?
This looks like blade runner.
Yeah.
Maybe that movie's not so far off the
uh,
the one from Columbus,
Ohio blade runner.
Oh.
Like maybe they're only off by a year or
ready player.
One ready player.
One.
Have you seen the preview for that?
That's pretty much,
this is exact same thing as right here,
but this is the Microsoft one.
What does the differences,
magic leap movie.
So magically Biz,
not Microsoft.
Which one's the Microsoft one?
Uh,
that would be hololens.
Magic leap is the one that's in Florida.
They went way away from everybody else
so that they're not getting their
knology compromised by it.
And these are the ones where they had
that little a dancer.
The dances on your hand.
Oh,
okay.
So this is the really intense lifelike
augmented reality.
Nobody knew what it was going to look
like.
They thought any prototype had a big
giant backpack on and they finally got
it down to this little pocket.
This is the first time we're actually
seeing with this also might not be the
final version.
It could be smaller.
Could be a little bigger.
Exactly.
Looks cool.
It looks very cool.
It looks like Superhero.
Cool.
But the thing is,
is it,
it's so obvious that you're wearing it.
Yeah.
They need to get rid of that part and
integrate it into the headset.
There's like this hip part like
batteries plus to wear it in public at
least this,
this is probably like a home work type
thing,
like wherever you'd use a personal
computer.
I feel like we're looking at the seed of
a future thing that's going to eat us.
I'm looking at that.
I'm like that.
That is exactly how it starts.
The electronics cling to the outside and
become inseparable and then slowly they
work their way into the organism itself
to the inside.
The organism will accept symbiosis as
long as the electronics stay on the
outside,
but if it goes inside,
like if the only way you use your cell
phone was a stick it in your ass.
Right.
There's the only way it works.
We have a new cell phone and it works
all you have to just stick it in your
ass and then just carry it around with
you and you make calls with your mind
and it's a flip.
Yeah.
We would say,
no way we can't do it,
but as long as the electronics from the
outside,
like I said,
dude,
they're going to give you a helmet.
You get to the electronics going to go
right into your eyes.
You're gonna see some shit that's not
there.
You're like,
okay,
where bolt clothing's a tech is the
future.
Like there's even,
I think Levi's and Microsoft or google
teamed up and they're,
they're trying to do at jacket,
like a tech Jagger.
We just look at your jacket and read
text and stuff off the sleeve and stuff.
Imagine having a like a shirt and going
like,
today I want a purple shirt today.
I went to blue shirt.
Or you're getting text messages pop up
on your shirt.
Or if there's a lost child,
the child's face is on everybody's
shirt.
Fuck.
I think wearable clothings going to be
pretty big sin.
Yeah.
Especially if you could like,
if you could get your arm,
like it actually could open up like
where it looks like a screen.
Yeah.
Where if we can get that good where
there's no benefit like,
and nobody wants a cell phone with a
shitty screen.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Because like that,
isn't that like the big debate now they
all look amazing to me because I'm going
blind.
Barely.
See.
But the,
if I look at like the x
versus the Google Pixel,
two xl versus they all look really good.
Yeah.
It's more like brightness now to me it's
like,
oh,
this one,
it seems brighter.
I guess they all look really good.
They all look amazing.
I mean we're really nitpick and which is
good.
Just shows you how good things are.
But could you ever reproduce that on
your sleeve?
Yeah,
they already have that.
Perfect.
Well like,
like the technology is not 100% there,
but they already have bendable lcds.
Right.
And like stuff like that.
But the thing is having it feel like
clothing and of like this big chunk
that's on your shirt,
like these things you see at the mall.
But I like,
I had this,
uh,
I was talking to Gino speed,
we'd about this and the idea of having a
hat.
Imagine the hat where you can have any
logo you want under your hat.
You could change at any day.
And then you can also have it so it's
just moves or something.
Like if it's the Nike swoosh you see
like the smoke coming out of the,
you know,
how cool would that be just,
and it's weird that we don't see that as
a normal thing yet cause it seems like
that's already there.
You could do that hat right now.
Probably have a little three g
connection so you can download things on
it.
You know,
using the little thing on the top of the
hat.
Yeah you probably could button,
you probably could.
I mean what,
anything that you can imagine in the
future is probably going to be possible.
Like anything,
anything you could imagine.
I don't think there's are going to be a
time in our lifetime we're,
we're change is going to happen as
quickly as it's happening now.
What about shoes?
Where,
where you could just have like instead
of walking your shoes,
just roll in Aleks like kind of lied
along wide.
Yeah.
Well isn't that
WHO's always goofing around about the
aliens?
The aliens are,
is what we imagined as us in the future.
Maybe that's what they really are.
Maybe that they're time travelers.
Cause if he had to think,
like if you go back and look at ancient
like Australia pithy gets you ever see
like a depiction of Australia pivotus
it's like this weird sorta half human
monkey things like one of the first
people.
And if you go back and look at that and
then you look at a regular person today,
that may be,
you know,
it takes a spin class and you know,
go see if they go to the one where he's
standing up,
there's some pictures of what they think
they would have looked like.
It's weird because there is people that
look kind of like these people.
You sure?
Yeah.
Some people that are pretty hairy too.
I mean they think there's,
there's all sorts of different kinds of
people too.
That's another thing that we forget.
There was a bunch of different kinds of
people that died off.
But the idea is all these people write
all these different kinds of little
people.
They eventually evolve to be human,
right?
If they stay alive,
they get to a point.
Well,
what happens if you pass the human
thing?
Do you just stop at human?
I don't think you could stop it human
when this is not perfect.
This is not perfect.
This is better.
It's better than it,
you know,
killing each other with rocks in the
trees.
It's better than that,
but it's definitely,
we're getting better at this.
It's obvious we're getting better at
being people collectively.
So like where does it go?
Does it go to,
we just move everything with our brains
and our heads or that big robot and we
fuck up the environment so bad that we
need sunglasses permanently on the
outside.
And that's what those alien,
the black eyes.
So we just fixed it.
We just give you a fake lens.
Your skin's like bulletproof and you
move everything into your brain.
Nobody needs a mouth anymore.
No sex organs.
It got too complicated gender.
This is the year like this is the
machines confused us and got us to the
point where they could deliver orgasms
through like little little injections in
the back of your brain.
You just give way more intense orgasms
and you would ever get jerking off or
having sex.
And so everybody just stopped having sex
and you're our dicks and vaginas just
shy.
They just sealed up.
We figured out food to the point where
now there's no more waste,
so no one has has to shit.
We just nailed it.
That's perfect balance.
No one's ever overweight.
It's how they have sex and demolition.
They put those headsets on and sit
across from each other.
Oh yeah.
They had their feet in the water.
It's not water.
It looks like water.
Yeah.
It's where they'd girl drips into.
That's so strange.
That's how they had sex.
You know?
That's probably going to be better.
We gave it this physical thing.
We gave it a shot.
It's too costly.
Okay.
Did the food thing makes the most sense?
Because we are probably going to run out
of food in having like the future of
food is going to be really weird where
it's just going to be like almost like
a,
a break.
Like I vitamin,
well there's my steak,
you know?
There's,
yeah man.
Right.
The future of food.
Yeah.
Like when they're,
you know,
there was some article it real recent,
like I think maybe even today that was
talking about,
um,
their progress and synthetic meat.
It'd be able to just make meat and
laboratory,
which is rule.
That's a game changer.
Don't they already have it where you can
buy it.
Now I feel like I was gonna bring this
up the other day when you talked about
fat Burger has the impossible burger.
Oh,
but that's some plant based meat.
Yeah,
that's,
but that's dinner lab mate.
No,
no,
no.
That's some,
they've had those for a while.
Um,
people who are Vegan who used to like
cheeseburgers apparently say that this
works.
Yeah.
That you could,
you can literally,
they,
they've looked,
but there's some smart people out there.
They figured out a way to make things
taste different than what they really
are.
There's a bunch of Vegan cheeses and
shit that are really good,
but that's not what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about lab created meet
actual meat that somehow or another
they,
they have some cloning process or
something.
Yeah.
I saw something about the other day and
they're pretty much there if not
completed with it.
I Dunno.
That's the,
if they can do that,
that's fine.
If it tastes the same,
I would go with lab created me.
Yeah,
lab created meat.
It's probably better for you.
Geez.
I just,
I'm just imagining like,
you know what I'm imagining power outage
warehouse filled with lab created meat
stuck in the pipes.
Oh,
do you think the expiration date is on a
lab created meat forever?
Yeah,
they just engineer it with the right
bacteria so I could stay on the shelf
and definitely,
I remember making a mistake that the
first time that grocery store I had
these things called the complete meals.
I don't know what the fuck it's called,
but there's like meat,
like a biscuits and gravy but not in the
cold section.
Not In the hot section.
And you barely had to heat it up.
It was just kind of ready to go meals
and my friend ate it.
But I think we both got sick as fuck
this.
So disgusting.
But I mean they're still out there.
This was seven years ago.
It's like those little meals for kids
that aren't really food.
What's his little lunchables?
Lunchables.
Those things are the worst for people.
That's not even food.
Yeah.
Those little cheese things.
He's take a cracker in.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh those are so gross.
Some of them.
Some,
some.
Somebody must have a good one.
Bye now.
Good little like starbucks has like a
decent little snack pack,
right?
Don't they have one with like celery and
beets and shit?
Sure.
Yeah.
They have all this stuff.
Starbucks is pretty good.
AMC movie theaters has waffles and
chicken now.
Did you know that?
That's amazing.
But I think the healthy option thing is
because people demand it.
Right?
Cause there's a bit,
why wouldn't they have it is like
there's,
there's money in it.
Yeah.
If you go to starbucks sometimes if
you're trying to not taking too much
sugar or something like that,
you look at all that stuff and you're
like,
God damn it.
It's gotta be something in here for me.
What's your for me?
Like you got all your tasty I site
options.
Right?
Like those cake pops.
I'm like,
damn,
I just go off the reservation and get a
fucking cake pop.
Right.
It's like weird.
Like they're really,
they're selling sugar just as much as
they're selling coffee,
which is great.
Have you had the Bantam bagels,
the Bagel balls or they're amazing.
They're amazing.
They,
I used to like their chocolate
croissants but then I found um,
the coffee beans,
chocolate croissants to be more
delectable.
So if I was going to go off,
I go to the coffee bean.
Don't mess with that.
I don't,
don't mess with starbucks.
I just got it.
You have a relationship at starbucks?
It's just right next door.
Every time I get a coffee bean though,
when you get used to certain tastes of
coffee,
even if the coffee is better,
it's really to go like,
that's not an ice coffee in my head in
ice coffee,
starbucks,
iced coffee.
This is just like some other bullshit.
Like I went to Denny's the other day,
maybe the best coffee I've had in a long
time and you can't buy that anywhere.
You have to go to denny's.
Yeah.
They don't sell you denny's coffin.
I was looking for a k cup for it,
you know,
they look correct.
Cups speaking
Denny's is a,
that's probably like the biggest
breakfast chain ever,
right?
Yeah,
it's gotta be,
it's like I hop and Dennis,
those are the two
you could have.
There's like a standard you like,
there's a balance between how delicious
it is,
how cheap it is.
You gotta be real careful with that
balance.
You know,
like it's a different concept than a
regular restaurant,
like a regular restaurant.
But it is a regular restaurant,
right?
I mean,
I hops a fucking regular restaurant and
Burger there the other day,
but even if you eat there,
you like,
even if you eat healthy there,
you're like,
oh,
I fucked up with die off.
Right.
Because everything is so delicious.
You look at it whipped cream on top of
shit and a menu and those marriage,
she know cherries and you're like,
oh Jesus,
this is at Ihub.
Okay.
And then you have that row of syrup
already on your table.
I think I want to add blueberry taste to
it.
If you're gonna just go off ihops the
spot to go off,
right?
The story.
Yeah.
South Carolina,
man hilariously cooks himself breakfast
at Waffle House while employees sleeps.
Oh my God.
That's funny.
Yeah,
he's taking pictures.
The guys just asleep in the corner.
Oh my God.
That is hilarious.
Is that illegal?
Could those guys get in trouble for
that?
Okay.
Maine taking the pictures and
incriminating yourself?
Probably not the smartest move and
putting them online,
but probably not.
That's a good question.
It's like a no harm,
no foul kind of thing.
I think.
No harm,
no foul.
We got hurt in this situation.
I wonder if he put money down now.
He said he came back.
It says he came back the next day and
gave a $5 tip.
Wow.
Okay.
One employee working whole waffle house.
What if,
what if like 10 people walk in?
20 people walking.
That seems weird.
That seems ridiculous.
I hate waffle.
Waffle houses are amazing.
You like Raphael good.
Yeah man.
If you're on the road,
it's like three o'clock in the morning
until like the greatest things that have
ever existed.
If you're on the road,
like let's pick up some weird spot in
South Carolina or something like that.
That's exactly where this was.
Ooh.
What's Columbia?
Less Cold Sea Jesus that was just out
there.
Straight up.
Guess
all the waffle house's in Ohio are like
connected to strip clubs.
So I always considered it being like
gross food because yeah,
I don't know.
Yeah man,
I,
we probably been about 10 of those on
the road.
Yeah,
they're always like a good option.
It's also 24 hours,
so,
yeah,
that's right.
That's why it's so crazy.
That's why it gets weird.
Waffle houses get weird.
3:00
AM New Year's Eve waffle house.
All it takes is one crazy person to walk
in.
Guy Fieri era.
I just had to close his restaurant.
You say that with Glee.
Why do you do that?
No,
I just called Miss Ohio native.
We have to,
you've got to support your own.
No,
I'm just saying that that went fast.
You know,
all die theory is a,
um,
he's a funny guy.
Yeah.
Okay.
I like how he wearing,
I like people that wear their sunglasses
backwards on their neck.
What you don't want,
I don't get with him is why so many
people get rick a guest.
They don't like that he spikes his hair.
They don't,
what is it that they don't like?
I think it's just an easy target.
I don't know.
I mean he seems nice.
I met him once.
He was nice.
I don't care if he likes to wear his
hair like that.
It's like a don king thing.
Am I mad at Don King?
He can't change his look.
That's what he's known for it.
Is it racist as a white guy with blonde
hair spikes his hair up and people just
automatically assume you're a Douche.
Is that racist?
Like a nickelback thing?
Like people don't really hate that
model.
I mean they probably did a little bit,
but I wear my hair like that sometimes.
Yeah.
Billy Corgan,
I don't know if he was trolling or not.
Um,
I don't think he was,
he,
he was talking to me about how good he
thinks nickelback is.
Oh,
I think nickelback has some fuck good
songs.
I do what I do.
I know the first day of the main prompt
people had little man.
I listen,
I enjoy the way that a rock star song
sounds.
I know that's sort of a,
a song that's been covered,
you know,
like that's,
that style of song has been covered a
few times.
Right.
But I liked that one.
I mean I like the Cypress Hill one
better.
Remember?
So if you want to be a rock star,
you know,
it's the same thing.
It's the same thing.
Yeah.
It's like there's a style of song of
like describing what it's the lifestyle
of a rock star.
So the only problem with the nickelback
song is that it had been done before
because if it hadn't been done before,
they did a really job covering that
subject.
Like their,
their take on it was,
was good.
It was very polished,
maybe too polished for some people.
We like Shit Ra.
We like to hear that Janis Joplin growl,
right?
We like to heat here,
amy winehouse.
There's something we like about that raw
shit to so remind us,
remind us.
You're just like us.
That's the problem.
I think some musicians have with
nickelback there sort of considered at
least they were and what's called like
an end the box type of bandwidth for
recording purposes.
I They Canadian.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's all it is.
So it is,
yeah.
Canadians are so nice.
You don't
believe him did this.
They would record,
uh,
no,
no.
Um,
affects on their sounds on their guitar
for instance.
No distortion,
no delay.
They'd record literally putting the
guitar right into this board,
kind of in it record this real weird
electronic sound that you could
manipulate completely in pro tools
later,
changing everything about it.
They were like one of the first bands
that got popular doing that,
I think.
And so that's sort of like,
I'm sure traditional musicians had a big
problem with it.
Isn't nickelback the band that like
every single one of their songs sound
exactly the same.
Like whiny
that guy.
It's not whiny.
Well,
it's like,
I wouldn't say whiny.
I'd say it's poppy.
It's like very good pop music.
I mean we'll try and be nice here.
I don't,
I like a lot of their songs,
but I'm trying to be nice here.
Like I understand if people would get
upset that it's not their style in
music,
you know,
it's people that like like real level.
They'll play something for you.
Like to play the Beatles like
okay,
lucy in the sky with diamonds.
He put on some headphones and listen to
a loose smoke,
a joint,
put on some headphones and listen to a
song that was created by the first wave
of British superstars that came to
America and they're on acid and the
saying about lucy in the sky with
diamonds and it's,
it's amazing.
It's amazing.
Do that.
Okay.
Right now,
do you want us to do it right now?
Just thinking I want to,
I want to think about this for a second.
Okay.
Just imagine,
imagine what it was like back then.
Imagine,
imagine being in like 1960 whatever the
fuck it was when all this was going on.
What do you plan the background?
It takes forever.
I thought I was going crazy after my two
stone.
I'm having a dad.
I was listen to led Zeppelin came on
last night and I forgot.
I don't know how to say the word.
Dear dire maker.
How do you say it?
Yeah,
it's a bad ass song.
I forgot.
Oh Dude.
There's so many good songs.
There's so many good songs now.
This is the thing.
The songs are better.
They're better than nickelback.
Yeah,
right.
It's not mold,
but nick or backs not bad saw that.
It's just,
if you want to compare Jimi Hendrix to
the rest of the world,
the rest of the world's going to suck a
fat deck.
This,
there was a guy that knew how to do it
better than everybody else.
It doesn't mean that.
It doesn't mean Eric Clapton wasn't an
amazing guitarist.
It means everybody always looks at Jimmy
Hendrix in a better way.
For whatever reason,
Matt,
for whatever reason,
you know,
I'm sure there's people that would see
it the opposite way.
It doesn't mean nickelback socks.
They've gotten your man,
Bro.
Like they just word the Beatles,
you know,
but that's like a,
I guess there's a different category
between like,
you know,
they Beatles led Zeppelin and Nicole
Vac,
right?
Maybe there is,
but maybe we should just relax.
I mean,
I'll take two smash mouseover I'm just
saying maybe we should just relax like
about everything.
I think we're picking,
we're looking for tribal enemies that
don't exist,
you know,
just because you like to eat,
you know falafels and,
and you know,
like extra ketchup on your fries and I
don't,
you know,
or you,
you like to go running and I like to
take naps.
You know,
who cares?
This is,
this is my perspective in 2018 I think
the more we can relax that we will have
less conflict,
interpersonal conflict,
which often fuels extra personal
conflict.
It's 2018 and let it go.
You can like nickelback I told somebody
that I like Ellie King and uh,
they gave me like a sidewards face.
I'm like,
fuck you.
I don't even hit that is,
you know who that is?
You ever heard that song x's and o's?
Oh Dude,
she's bad ass x isn't her whole album is
bad ass.
What is that?
Uh,
what does that,
that album called,
do you call it an album anymore?
Because it used to be a c it was an
album and then you were an old man if
you were calling it an album,
it's a cd Bro.
And then it stopped being a CD and it
became an album again.
I download it.
I just say I downloaded it.
What do you say?
Do you say you say it's an outlet?
Call it CD.
I still say CTA,
I think.
I don't think I do album.
I mean,
do you remember when people would mock
you if you said album?
Cause they'd be like,
you mean cd?
It's his cd now called the CD.
Like,
oh,
okay.
Okay.
That was like a phase where people got
conti about the distinctions between cds
and albums and then all of a sudden
vinyl made a little comeback during the
CD era,
people decided that vinyl was a,
how would you describe a Jamie?
What's the,
what's the difference between the sound?
Oh,
it's warmer.
It's got a nice warm,
you always say warmer.
That eight out vinyl is huge now.
So big.
Like I went to a vinyl store the other
day that was like being in a record
store in the 70s like I was like,
it was all vinyl.
What people are digging it,
man.
They,
they,
they get into it.
It's a tactile relationship with the
music.
That's what Henry Rollins was explaining
it to me.
And the way he describes it,
it's really intoxicating because he's
such an an an addict to that kind of
music and he has a whole set up in his
house where these crazy speakers that
are like stupid expensive and he has
this amazing record collection and he'll
just sit there and play his records and
he does a radio show,
I believe it's once a week.
Is it once a week?
He does a radio show once a week where
he picks the songs and he plays the
music.
It's all his selections.
What does it on Kr kcrw.
Here's this great speakers.
Yeah.
So he's got these fucking nutty ass
speakers,
man.
Look at these things and he stands in
front of these things and I really
enjoyed talking to him,
man.
He's an uniquely unusual person.
I always thought he was like,
I am going to be completely honest.
When he was a young guy and he did that,
uh,
beavis and butthead thing,
liar.
Do you remember that?
Why it Beavis and butthead?
It was hilarious,
dude.
He had an amazing song called Ama Liar.
You ever seen rollins?
You don't know that song.
There's like one of his breakout hit
songs as a connected with that and he
was super jacked.
That was in his full on power lifting
days.
And I remember seeing him go at this guy
is like way too intense.
How is this a fucking cigarette?
A band.
That guy looks like he wants to rip your
fucking head clean off your body and
just pull your guts through your neck
hole.
He looked so crazy scary and uh,
I could never figure it out.
I was like,
that's so weird that this guy is,
um,
I forgot a singer.
In my mind,
a singer had to be a certain type of
person.
They had to be a Jon Bon Jovi or they
had to be Robert Plant.
They had it,
you know,
there was a style that you could be a
singer and he was just completely new,
weird thing.
This jacked up power are covered in
tattoos.
I was like,
whoa.
But when you meet him,
I mean maybe it's cause I'm meeting him
later in his life when he's mellowed and
matured,
but he is one of the most fascinating
guys I've ever talked to.
One of the most absolutely unique
individuals.
Like,
oh,
I never met one at you.
The guy is obsessed with productivity
and work and creating obsessed with it.
His writing,
he writes for like a bunch of different
publications,
constantly writing,
constantly traveling,
goes to places,
just gets on a plane,
flies over to that spot,
lands with buys water and starts fucking
meeting people.
It doesn't know where the fuck he is.
Just puts himself in these weird
positions and some of them like super
dangerous,
fascinating guy,
man.
Never met a guy like him.
I heard him on our,
he's podcast,
one of the,
one of the main um,
podcast that he did that really like
fucking blew my mind was him describing
all this travel that he does on Ari show
cause you know,
our,
he's a travel nut too.
So the two of them together,
it's like wow.
I think he probably was one of the
inspirations or at least help fuel the
inspiration that Ari had when he already
took off for like four months.
I didn't know he was on Ari's podcast.
That's a good catch for Ari.
It's an amazing episode.
I believe they were in Edinburgh.
I believe they were there for the fringe
festival in Edinburgh and I think that
our was performing and um,
he,
he's going to get mad.
I know he told me this story and I don't
remember it.
You hear a lot of stories though.
I heard too many.
Somehow or another,
someone set it up,
but um,
it's a great podcast nonetheless,
however it transpired.
But Henry Rollins is a,
here it is.
Not all those who wander are lost.
That's exactly what the name is.
Skeptic tank two 77 yeah.
So now awesome podcast.
I mean like a life changer.
Like you listen to that podcast and his,
what?
He gets out of travel,
you go,
oh yeah.
Why wasn't I looking at it that way?
Like know why was I just going to places
going up?
Can they drink the water?
Is this safe?
Like what is this?
Okay,
where's he's going over there going,
hell,
what do you do man?
What's going on?
Like,
what do you,
what do you people up to?
He's like,
really?
Like going into uncharted territories
all the time or on a regular basis,
picks a spot in the map.
Just goes like,
that's one of the things that I've
always said about Ari.
I like people who just go for it,
you know,
like Ra should fear just goes for it.
It takes you,
goes away for like four months.
He just vanishes.
He goes forward with how he does comedy.
You know,
I'm gonna go do comedy in China,
you know,
he just goes for it.
It'd be funny if when he vanishes,
but he actually has another life that he
doesn't tell anybody about family kids,
the husband didn't he have an entire
nother life when you guys did a podcast
together and Ari did Salvia on your
podcast and he,
the way he described it,
his like he,
I'm not conflating these,
right.
This is,
am I confusing this?
This is when it was the same.
He did it on your podcast and then this
was the Salvia trip where he said that
he lived like a whole life for like
three months and there was something
with water in a bus or something like
that.
Well,
there was he,
I'm sure he's described it somewhere.
Yeah,
a Reddit Ama.
I think he felt like he had lived a
whole life like for months,
a whole different life for months.
And then came back from that trip.
Like it just happened.
He realized,
Oh my God,
no,
I just took Salvia.
They really got rid of Salvia fast,
didn't they?
You remember when that was legal,
you'd just buy it online and then two
within like a year,
they just kind of took care of Salvia.
What is little distinction legally for
Salvia now it's the scheduling.
They went fast on that legal marijuana
but lip.
Amen.
But Dude Salvias Ooh,
stronger than marijuana.
Oh,
this is what people didn't know you.
People were going to their pot dealers
and they trying to,
you know,
get some good weed.
Why you want to have a good experience?
Salvia used to be for sale at head shops
everywhere and it was one of the most
Bolo out of your fucking mind.
Psychedelics you could ever encounter
right now.
You still buy it.
I used to buy it.
Careful Times 80 concentrated 20 x right
here,
one 20 eggs,
cheese.
It's even stronger now.
Oh my God,
I bet it's not legal.
You should.
I wonder if it shows what states they
will ship to or if you try to buy it.
It tells you like,
Hey,
this is a legal and illegal in most
parts of the world and here's the,
here's the big problem with all these
things.
I think all these things could be
handled way better than they have been.
So people are going buck wild with them,
whether it's mushrooms or whether it's a
lsd or anything.
People left these important compounds in
the hands of people that were willing to
take them illegally and that's where
most of our data's coming from because
they couldn't do any tests on anything.
Everything was just scheduled one
schedule one.
But the people that tested it,
there are people willing to take
mushrooms.
It's a lot of people did with just white
knuckle.
That shit to death.
Me included at various times in my life,
he tried to bring me mushrooms.
I'd white knuckle myself to death.
So it was the people,
the only sampling size that we have from
the benefits that people that were wild
enough to do it.
Like what if we had actual scientists
studying the shit go,
hey,
maybe we took the stuff and like low
doses.
We could evolve quicker.
Like this really might be something.
There might be something legitimate to
the idea that stoned ape theory is that
humans discovered psilocybin mushrooms
and that's why the brain grew like
double its size over a period of 2
million years.
That's the theory,
I think.
Right?
Mushrooms could have totally been in
that mix with all the other stuff too.
All the other stuff.
The throwing arm hunting is a film on
the naughty show podcasts for an old
death squad studio.
Oh,
it said what happened was I took a hit
of Salvia,
but I didn't quite take a big enough hit
or I didn't hold it long enough so it
took me right to the edge of
disappearing into my mind,
but I didn't quote it,
but it didn't quite get me through the
barrier.
So I took another hit.
This time the hit was as big as I could
possibly muster.
It was massive and I held it for a
really long time.
That hit alone would have been enough to
make me obliterate my consciousness,
but that hit coupled with the one from
before that all that got me almost
there,
put me in another place.
I was in a lake in the backyard of my
childhood home,
but I wasn't me swimming there.
I was a new being who lived underwater.
It took me a little bit of time to learn
how to breathe water,
but then I learned and I was there for a
while.
I mean like months at least I estimate I
was there anywhere from four months to
two years.
I made friends.
I had a life
all underwater.
At some point,
my new life,
I saw Sam Aaa at the store,
at the shore of the lake,
so I swam up to him to investigate.
Pratt says he was just sitting in the
chair across from me.
In reality,
that's when they started pulling me back
into this existence,
but what they didn't know was that I
couldn't breathe air anymore.
I've forgotten how after breathing
underwater for so long,
I had to relearn the experience of
breathing.
They says,
man,
that was a good trip.
It looked Talus if you watch the video.
But what's important to understand is
that the,
that the hellish part was not me wanting
to leave my friends,
family and life and the lake.
It was just adjusting back to this
reality that hurt.
But the months or years I was living
there with some of the most beautiful
and peaceful of my life.
Oh Shit.
Ours brain broke.
I know now.
Now I should look at the video and
imagine that he lived there for four
years.
It's totally different when he say,
no,
I feel bad for getting them into drugs.
Look here now.
Here's what the four years he went
through,
you're allowed to play audio.
The smuggling,
he's still holding.
He's sleeping or dead.
So this is a,
a video that we're watching that all
took place in Brian's apartment.
I think he's dead.
Somebody give me is fucking funny.
Stop.
Oh my God.
You had to shush people.
Well,
it's like he was chairman heart.
I didn't want him to freak out.
Right.
Good call.
See,
I'm Tripoli.
Shut your mouth.
Who else was there?
Triple anywhere else.
Aaa.
Jason Teebo,
Alison
and Maddie.
Kirsch maybe.
Oh,
what a great time to trip people staring
at you talking mad shit while you're
blown out of your mind into another
dimension grab.
Oh Wow.
Tell us this long.
So I think probably people,
because this is all right,
you can find this is something you got
it.
It only works visually,
but if you see it visually,
it's fascinating.
So it's a Ari Shaffir on Salvia and it's
on Brian's.
Is it on yours or it's on it.
So on red bands,
a youtube page,
Ari Shaffir on Salvia Salvias wide every
quarter.
Ari Salvia is why it never did dmt
because I had too many like,
okay,
I'm too old for this.
I might break my brain moments that I'm
like,
I don't need to do anymore.
Yeah,
there's,
there's some weird weird drugs out
there.
Re we're really,
really weird ones.
And part of the problem with like legal
definitions for what what is and isn't
legal,
there's like gets,
it gets kind of weird and blurry.
Like there was some stuff called five
Meo dimethyltryptamine,
which is the most potent form of,
of DMT.
And up until like the year 2000 and like
you'd be able to order it online.
They would just send it to you.
It's illegal.
Just says not for human consumption were
like,
I don't know what you're doing with it,
but here it is pure and you'd be able to
get enough to blast yourself in the
universe every day of your life until
you're dead for like 50 bucks.
It was crazy.
It was the wild west because people
didn't know what it was yet because they
had made a distinction that n n
dimethyltryptamine,
which is the one that gives you all the
visual hallucinations,
that that was more illegal.
That was,
that was the moment.
That was a schedule one drug that was,
but they had listed five methoxy diamond
field trip to me.
So it was in this weird state of limbo.
Salvia.
They just missed it.
What?
That stuff the fuck outta here.
I can't believe it's Smith.
Steagall did.
This is probably a shitload of those in
the Amazon.
There's probably a shit load of things
that are not,
never been discovered.
Nini eat some fruit and you fucking go
blast off into the center of the
universe.
I bet.
I bet that,
I bet if we could allow,
if we all decided,
all right,
we're going to leave.
Let's,
let's have humans live everywhere except
one really big spot.
No people can live at this one really
big spot.
We got to manage like other kind of
ecosystems in a more hands off sort of a
way because we're just so d like
separate like the Congo and places like
that,
but if there was like one country where
everybody agreed,
all right,
let's just leave this,
leave this spot alone.
No one go in there.
Let's see what happens.
Let's see how nature evolves while we
observe it with modern methods.
Just like step back for a few hundred
years just as a human project.
Let's see what kind of shit grows in
there.
If you just leave it alone because we're
so fucking snippy.
Snippy.
Let me get in there and let me dig.
Let me fucking cut these down and I'll
plant new ones.
Don't worry about it bro.
I'm to plant new ones.
Dude.
I got this,
I cut down the forest and put some new
ones on.
Not Saying that I'm not hypocritical
sitting here in front of a wood desk,
you know,
I'm not saying don't do it,
but
I mean think of how weird that is.
If we could just leave all that shit
alone,
who knows what kind of weird symbiotic
relationships we could have had with
plants that might have easily been how
they came up with Iowasca in the first
place.
It probably eating a bunch of weird
fucking plants and all those plants.
We're talking with all those other
plants and I'm like,
listen,
I know.
I know where we can get just shit
bumping way quicker.
We got to get these monkey people to to
figure out how to eat these mushrooms
and turn it to regular people.
Imagine,
imagine if that's really what it was all
long just grasses and leaves
communicating to us through some
nonverbal language and and giving us
this idea of how to do certain things
and
the,
all these things are all just designed
to get us to eat the mushrooms we eat.
The mushrooms get to the point where we
accelerate to the point we have enough
brain power and enough people combined
interacting with each other and sharing
information that we can build artificial
life.
And then that becomes the new thing.
Or along the way we become the aliens.
We've figured out how to use that crispr
technology,
crispr technology.
You know what that is.
It's some new thing.
Uh,
I brought up on the podcast a lot,
so if you've heard it before I
apologize,
but it's some sort of a,
I'm going to butcher the definition
again.
It's some sort of a genetic,
um,
uh,
altering system that they're,
they're creating a gene changing system
where they can do things to the human
body potentially,
uh,
where they can alter genetics that can
alter DNA.
It's very complicated and I'm doing a
terrible job describing it would,
it has essentially let me,
for a dumb person like me,
really super smart people have figured
out a way to change biology.
They might be able to turn genes on and
off like for autism for Alzheimer's,
like weird weird genes that create birth
defects or various illnesses that we've,
we've been able to figure out how to
target.
They might that we identify whether they
might be able to target those things.
They will shut things off,
turn things on.
And I think there was an article really
recently saying that the original crispr
is now even out of date and the new one
is far superior there did just getting
better at it.
They're going to,
they shot some shit into some dude.
Uh,
there was a guy who had a disease and it
was,
I believe it was an incurable disease.
He was the first human recipient of
crispr technology.
That's like seeing it as science fiction
movie.
Right.
You hear about the first guy that gave
it a chance to Chris or Christopher and
2.0
is here and it's way more precise.
See if you could find the article about
the guy that was the first human
recipient for crisper.
Why is it spelled like that?
Like,
like a 14 year old emo kid wrote in the
basement.
Like there's no e it's a CRI s p r I
think they wanted it to be catchy.
And uh,
I think it's also,
what is that an acronym?
It's an acronym,
right?
Yeah.
I always fuck up acronym.
And the other one,
like what's the dea?
It's an acronym.
That's an acronym.
I thought it was an acronym when you
said it,
but that's not what it could become as a
word.
Yes.
I don't think it meant yes.
Right.
NASA,
like you say,
you don't say the n Asa.
Right.
So what's the difference when those,
I think NASA isn't,
is that I'm so dumb now that it's just
weird,
you know,
knowledge and an abbreviated form of the
initial letters of other words and
pronounced as a word,
as a word.
Okay.
So NASA would be an acronym.
So I was right.
I was dumb as I thought that one of the
drag,
I was super nervous.
I am,
Oh,
I've always been insecure about,
uh,
those kinds of things like that.
You're probably should know like what an
acronym is.
Like,
I don't know that any of that shit
anymore.
How do you even remember it was talking
about something I saw or was your mind
is more that I saw him planners to this
weekend or is it just came on Netflix.
So good.
There's this island that only birds can
get onto and honest island is a tree
that has the seeds that um,
are sticky seeds.
So they get stuck onto the birds.
And when the birds travel from island to
island,
they kind of drop them off or whatever.
But also the seeds can kind of trap the
birds there and they can end up now just
had right there.
They can get die because they can't get
too many of them get stuck in the birth,
gets stuck and then they end up falling
onto the ground and then get absorbed
into the ground and eating the plants.
Sort of eat them,
if you will.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's kinda crazy.
Whoa.
That's okay.
But here's the thing,
is that coincidence is,
is just like dumb luck evolution I
suppose.
Yeah,
I think that's,
yeah,
it's dead birds.
Maybe evolution is like a word that's so
under fire.
Okay.
With the a lot of people,
maybe this is because the,
the,
the ramifications of it that it's,
that we're not even,
we're not even going to be,
the final thing is going to be something
like
where did Darren does,
that's how he found out about Darwin's
Galapagos Islands where he went the
first time.
Imagine going in there for the first
time and see and all sorts of crazy,
you know what's really fucked up.
People have gone there and they go there
with shit in their shoes and seeds from
their shoes get into the Galapagos
islands and non native plants start
growing and they identify that it comes
from literally from people like walking
through fields near their house and
wherever the fuck they live and then go
to the Galapagos and walking around and
that island is so,
it's been so isolated that it's as like
delicate immune system that they have to
monitor and just the cracking or shoe
could have a seat in it.
Yeah.
Do you know there's a lot of those
islands.
I heard the craziest story.
It's a story about goats that these
pirates was it pirates?
Hmm.
I might've made that part up,
but these old sailors,
these old sailors used to,
uh,
used to bring goats to islands and they
would let the goats off so the goats
could populate the island and then they
would have things to eat when they would
come back.
Cause goats eat everything.
Goats are savage goats in the sailors
diet during the golden age of piracy.
Okay.
I didn't make it up.
See,
I'm so paranoid.
So paranoid being stupid funny though,
if you,
but it's true.
So they would,
uh,
show up.
They would put these goats,
they would bring boatloads of goats and
does leave them on an island and they
would say,
next time we're around this area,
we got food.
Just go to these stupid goats.
They eat everything.
But that's the thing,
man.
They eat fucking everything.
They devastate ecosystems.
I had a friend who had goats.
He had goats.
He has this really sweet ranch,
and he had goats.
He's like,
oh,
I'll just have goats.
They'll trim up the lawn and it'd be
great.
But the fuck they do,
they eat everything.
Everything.
They just eat,
man,
you just leave shit out.
They eat that and they need everything
else too.
They roses,
they eat all your vegetables.
You get,
there's not a tree that's growing.
They're eating everything.
They just go through a hillside.
People use them.
They have like,
uh,
like services where companies have
trained goats and they bring them to
your farm or wherever the fuck you want
to just let these goats Lou.
And it's just like eats everything.
They just,
they shit all over the place.
They eat all over the place and they
just keep going.
They're hilarious though.
Yeah.
So they,
so they had a problem with these goats
on one of these pristine islands.
There's too many of them.
So what they did is they took one of
them and they put a collar on them so
they could always locate them.
They captured him and I think they,
they snipped him.
They gave him a little,
a vasectomy,
so he couldn't make any more goats.
And then goats always flocked to other
goats.
So what they would do is this one guy
with the collar,
they would use him to locate the other
goats.
Then they would gun them all down from
the sky,
so they would fly over and they're like,
up there.
There we found him tucked.
I thought that that gun down all these
fucking vegetable eating goats at it
invaded this island.
It's a,
it's a crazy podcast,
I believe.
I'm trying to remember the name of it
was on radio lab,
which isn't even a sponsor,
but I bring it up three times a month.
Galapagos just called Galapagos.
Yeah,
so it is about that very island is about
Galapagos and it's about these goats
that they just decided at a certain
point in time with it.
You have to control the populations of
them or they're going to devastate
everything else.
There's a massive imbalance.
Somebody fucked up.
They brought goats to a place where
there's no predators,
like goats are supposed to be around,
like lions and shit.
You know,
they're not supposed to be just by
themselves,
just eating everything and going off.
It'd be fun to watch him do it.
Yeah.
It would be fun.
Jihirah right about that.
Utuber what he's going through.
Logan.
Paul.
I did read that.
Yeah.
He,
he films someone who had committed
suicide in Japan and he put it on his
youtube channel.
Yeah.
There,
I guess there's this forest at the,
the bottom of a volcano or something and
it called suicide for her,
its nickname suicide forest because
everyone just goes there to commit
suicide.
And he was going there supposedly to
film how it's haunted and then they find
a body and it's pretty gross.
How He,
you know,
how the video was a,
he kind of joked about it.
He used humor.
Jamie told me that the thumbnail had him
like posing with the guy,
you know,
in the background and,
and you know,
he's,
um,
I don't know anything about him,
but I know he's a youtube guy.
Right.
And he's doing stuff that he thinks is
interesting and provocative,
you know,
and for whatever reason,
the,
the dialogue that I had read was
something to the likes of that he had
done it to bring a,
he'll apologize for it,
which seemed obviously felt terrible
about the way people viewed it,
but that he said that,
um,
how did he describe it?
Um,
he was trying to bring some sort of a,
he thought he was going to bring some
sort of an awareness to suicide,
but it was like a clunky,
he just didn't do it right and prayed
the respect that it deserved.
He realized that he fucked up.
He's basically saying he's trying to do
something and you fucked up,
you know?
I don't know,
man.
It's pretty gross.
I just found out that he's not the same.
Like there's a Jake Paul and it look and
Paul,
I thought they were the same person.
Why blood?
Why is everyone okay,
matt?
I don't know what anyone's mad at him
for the mad at him because he showed you
something you didn't want to see.
Is that what it is?
Because the video,
he kind of like,
they were like,
look at his hands,
they're blue and oh and like kind of,
he kind of was very poor taste.
He also advertised it like the day
before,
like I had this crazy sick video you
guys are going to freak out about and
you should have like that.
Oh,
so he got a chance to look at it and you
still approved it and then released it.
Yeah.
And then he made a thumbnail where it
looked like he posed for like photos
with a guy in the background.
It's very,
you know,
this was a person and,
and they're like laughing right next to
this body.
You know,
it's,
but I dunno,
that disturbs the shit out of us.
Right.
Like making,
like joking around.
He could joke around,
but he can't joke around near a dead
guy.
Well,
suicide's not funny,
so it's not,
if the guy died,
like natural causes,
no one's laughing.
The suicide,
the laughing at him,
joking around near the guy who committed
suicide.
Like,
I'm not saying you should do it.
You definitely shouldn't.
I don't want to see it.
But it's Kinda funny that we like
decide,
like you said,
just respectful bro.
But he didn't really do anything.
He just showed up and this guy was dead,
you know?
I'm not saying he should make fun of
him.
We definitely shouldn't,
but it's,
it's weird the outrage that we have for
it.
I'm sure he made a shit load of money
because I've got 7 million viewers and
you made money off it as suicide.
Yeah.
And you're talking about,
and we're talking about it,
we're helping them out.
Well,
the video got pulled,
but I guess I've got re uploaded a few
times.
He just made a second apology today
because the first apology a lot of
people said was very insensitive,
defending him.
Don't,
don't get me wrong,
I'm just exploring.
I look,
sometimes I try to look at things from
as many perspective as her,
Ken,
and I don't,
I don't,
uh,
I don't think that you ever want to make
fun of someone dying.
Right.
When you're right there and you're,
you're,
you're taking videos and you know,
it was a dead body hanging.
It's a terrible idea.
Now of 20.
This was 20 years ago.
It'd be okay.
Probably probably,
you know what,
the most horrific,
terrific
video or a photograph or other,
I think that a I ever saw about the
civil rights movement.
There's this photo of a,
all these weird white,
but like
if I remember correctly,
there's kids.
I remember counting.
I might've made that up,
but I remember these people standing
there while there was this black guy
hanging from a tree.
It might've been more than one black guy
and it's a,
it's one of those photos.
It just make you go,
whoa.
It's holy Shit.
They're one of the most disturbing
photos.
This is a right there.
Like look at that photo.
That's,
that is the exact photo.
Oh,
actually it a white guy there too.
That's weird.
We see a pirate.
The must have been something went wrong.
Photo actually says,
Oh get,
that's the real one.
That's the real one.
Son of a bitch.
That is the real one.
Now I remember God,
my memory's starting to suck.
The guy pointing up that looks like a
Hitler.
But those look like white guys too,
Bro.
Oh,
okay.
That's round.
Does it.
The guy on the left that's just like
light.
There's something super disturbing about
dudes with those old school press hats
on staring up at bodies,
hanging from ropes.
Fuck man,
that wasn't that long ago.
You know?
That's a,
that's what's horrifying.
But that was less than a hundred years
ago and it still happened probably
right?
What year was that?
No,
but by,
but that way,
1930 1930 holy Shit.
That that way was like accepted in 1930
wow.
All this sun new stuff like this magic
leap,
these headsets,
all these different things that we're
doing.
I think they're gonna.
I think we're in the middle of this so
it doesn't,
it's not registering is how fucking
ridiculous it is and how insane it is.
I think we're just so caught up in the
frothy waves of how crazy all this new
shit is that we're not,
we're not really paying attention
enough.
This is,
this is happening way quicker than I
thought it was going to.
We went flying cars by now though.
Now he's going to be robots.
Those Boston dynamic backflip in
gymnastics robot's going to win the
Olympics because other than proven they
can do it.
Is there any benefit in a robot being
able to do a backflip?
Dude,
could you imagine those no benefit just
to look cool.
I just wanted to check.
No,
no,
not at all.
Could you imagine if I'm the first robot
enters into the Olympics and then people
are like,
Hey,
what the fuck?
You can't do that.
Like,
no,
and he just,
we gave him all the strengths of a
regular person.
100% no more,
no less,
and he has feelings too,
so let them in there and don't be a
robot.
Phobic goes back to my one question.
What gender are the robots or the AI?
Females.
Yeah.
No,
you know what it
is.
They're,
they're the first neutral gender people
and there's so much happier.
There's neutral gender.
Nobody cares about gender.
Just be nice.
That's all they care about.
There's no boy,
girl.
They figured out a way to get past that
with that crispr shit.
That's what it is.
We seen that new sex robot.
You should get that for the stadium.
All right Brian,
you can order it now,
but you don't want the first models man
funnier that way.
One of them sharper image besides things
and breaks your desks.
They don't break you discs.
I think it'd be funny to have the first
version now had early version before
they have massage chairs.
They just have this actually asked,
they might've had massage chairs at the
same time,
but they had this thing that you would
grab a hold of.
It had like handles on the side and it
did like Shiatsu remember that thing?
It was like,
like little like little metal knuckles.
It would dig in your neck.
It's like,
this is amazing.
But uh,
when I was doing,
I was like,
how is this,
they're gonna someone's gonna get hurt
like some little old lady and you've
forced that fucking thing on their neck.
Like,
Yo,
be careful with this thing.
This thing's got some kicks
to it.
The best thing I ever found for that
kind of shit is a time massage.
You ever go get a time massage to stand
on you and stretch you out?
That's the shit.
Yeah,
that's better than any machine.
There's something about a person just
doing it.
Like getting in there with their elbow
is so much better than any machine.
Yeah.
I have this little girl I go to and she
has like the,
like the handles where she holds onto
and it's just digging her knee and your
back.
And I always say medium and it hurts
like hell.
I can't even imagine the hard one.
Ties have so many things nailed.
They can figure it out.
The best form of kickboxing,
you know,
Thai boxing changed everything.
It's weird.
This one small place figured out the way
to do it was the kick people's legs.
And you know how they figured it out,
man?
Gambling,
gambling made it profitable to have
fights all the time because people loved
gamble.
So they'd have all these people fighting
and ties.
They even altered their style to
accommodate the gambling.
Like the first round they would go real
slow because they wanted everybody to
place their bets.
So Pete,
they would just take it slow and
everybody knew the fight didn't really
begin to the second of the third round,
so it wasn't like American fighting
where you'd have like a Mike Tyson who
be cherished for knocking people out
very quickly.
Like,
like what?
Like there would be over under bets is
this guy is Tony Tubs gonna last the
first three rounds,
three minutes of the fight is Michael
spinks gonna last the first three like
world class fighters.
Dude magic get hit by Mike Tyson when he
was 20 years old mountain man.
How horrible that would be.
He was at the fights this past weekend.
I said,
I know him.
Hi Mike.
That's so weird.
It's
amazing.
He's still a tank to dude.
Terrifying looking person.
Or there's a video of him hitting the
bags like 51 years old or something like
that,
hitting the heavy bag and you're like,
oh,
okay.
You could still fuck you up.
Hundred percent like in terms of like
retired heavyweight champions,
there was a trend that existed.
You know where someone would retire and
then they would,
you know,
they wouldn't,
they wouldn't keep their form.
They would get heavy.
And that happened with Mike.
He got like very heavy look at this.
49 year old,
49 so this is like two years ago.
Yeah.
Fuck all this.
Give me some volume.
Fuck that dude.
49 year old Mike Tyson will put you to
sleep 100% and when you're around him,
you realize he like,
he's just,
who was that?
A rapper?
Meek Mill.
Oh,
that's,
oh,
make C.
I blame his trainers right there.
If I was the guy holding the camera,
it'd be like,
stop it.
Okay.
First of all,
we've got to straighten this whole thing
out before you start hitting hard.
You gotta you gotta move all this.
This might be just a personal trainer,
not a boxing person,
but I'm looking in the background and I
feel like I see boxing and stuff on the
wall.
They pray that played that video.
Young Mike Tyson with custom motto.
Oh my God,
I want to change the way you feel about
physics.
Custom motto was old and dying.
He was a really old guy,
but he had just this deep knowledge of
psychology and boxing and he trained
this unbelievably fast and powerful
talented kid who had massive hunger for
success.
The whole story of Mike Tyson,
a lot is wrapped up in the story of
custom auto who had been around forever,
and this is his last and greatest pupil.
And Mike [inaudible],
Mike knew it while it was happening,
and by the time he won the heavyweight
championship,
custom mono had already died.
But he dedicated it all to him.
There was nobody like him.
And you know,
people like,
they say,
Oh,
you know,
but he never fought Ali and he never
fought these guys that,
you know,
his era,
people weren't as good.
Maybe,
maybe,
but everybody in his era,
he fucked up all of them up until spanx,
or excuse me until I'm a bust the
Hendrix.
No.
Yup.
Well,
buster,
yeah,
buster was the first one to beat him,
but I meant uh,
holyfield.
Yeah,
that's how fucked up I am.
I said,
Hendrix,
I was trying to remember what the fight
was when holy field,
uh,
beat Tyson,
those two fights in a row like that was,
that was big.
And when Tyson bid,
his ear like that was big.
Like the,
that was like,
when you realize like he's just not,
he's not the same guy he was.
We both lived in Columbus when buster
douglas knocked him out,
that was a crazy,
like he became the big,
big fucking
hero.
No one knew who he was really.
I feel like when I was young,
but then he was supposed to take over at
the east side of the city.
He was gonna to change everything,
have a big giant boxing gym and never
happened.
We know the story of Buster Douglas,
it's an amazing story.
His mom died,
his mom died when he was in training for
the fight.
Oh really?
And all of his life,
he had kind of been really talented as a
boxer,
but hadn't really completely dedicated
himself to it.
So when his mom died,
he went completely insane in the gym in
preparation for Tyson.
And then when it came out that he,
it was like two people that had the
exact opposite things happen to them for
Tyson.
He had just been smashed and everybody
for so long,
he was so good and so scary.
He would win fights for the,
you could even start,
it would just be a matter of whether or
not you are going to make it out of the
first round.
Sometimes he's just smashing people.
But for Buster Douglas is like,
he had some good fights and some bad
fights and it just wasn't,
it wasn't completely consistent,
but he was talented.
But then when his mom died,
it was right when the time when Tyson
was,
you know,
just overconfident.
He was a 46 to one underdog I think.
Is that what it was?
It was marketed as Tyson is back fight,
which I didn't.
Oh Wow.
I didn't know that.
Tyson is back.
I don't remember that.
What,
um,
what were the odds,
because I think it was one of the
craziest odds of someone who want to
fight 42 to one.
It says 42 to one is a law.
That means you have to be a total sucker
to bet on Buster Douglas.
But I'll take your money.
Stupid.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'll give you $4,200
if you give me a hundred you know,
it's like they're so confident that
Tyson's going to beat them.
They're willing to bet 42 times whatever
you're going to put up.
That to me is always,
I think bets.
I'm not telling you what to do,
but I think bet she'd be like,
I think actually I,
I take it back.
I think it should be able do whatever
you want,
but I think the real bet should be who
do you want?
Who Do you think's going to win?
It's making it real clear who's going to
win.
If you say,
Oh,
well,
uh,
we'll Michael spanx making out of the
first round.
Like,
all right,
now we're getting weird because this is
some shit you might be able to effect.
Maybe you might be able to talk to Mike
and Mike.
There's a lot of money in this fight.
It was even more if we can get to the
second round,
you know what I'm saying?
Bro Know what I'm saying?
The last bit I liked that was Amanda
Nunez.
Yeah.
Kayo and the second round,
like specifically pick that.
That's very important to protect against
that kind of influence because that
Shit's real.
That shit's happened throughout sports.
If someone comes up to you and goes,
look,
there's a lot of money if this fight
goes into the third round.
So we're going to do look at his,
the ons 72 to [inaudible] 72 to one.
This fight goes to the third round.
Know what that means.
You let the vine go to the third round
and we'll make a lot more more.
Yeah,
I heard the,
uh,
a lot of people were a little worried
about the over under for Holly Holm.
Cyborg fight being only one and a half,
I think was the over under real or we
thought it probably was going to go away
longer.
That's a probably a gambling thing,
right?
Is that it has,
I think it has to do with the,
where the money sits.
Yeah.
But is that what he does?
I wish we knew.
Probably find out.
Find out.
Exactly.
But yeah,
I don't,
we used to talk to a gambling experts
sometimes on the old days of the UFC on
spike,
there were a guy would come on and he
would,
uh,
he would give us the odds to go local
oddsmaker type guy.
And he and I would even disagree about
shit sometimes.
God dammit.
I can't remember his name.
See if you can remember that gentleman's
name.
I feel terrible.
What was that Ugg boot you had on your
head?
Was that,
oh,
how dare you.
How dare you?
It's a,
I don't want to mispronounce it.
So yeah.
Is it like a religious thing or?
Um,
no,
it's uh,
from uh,
his,
his area of Dagestan,
they,
um,
I have it saved here on my thing cause
people been asking me,
uh,
in his area of Dagestan they,
um,
to where this thing it says,
it's what a warrior,
a mountain clan.
There are warrior mountain clan and that
this is what they're shepherds were.
And this is what you call it.
[inaudible].
I don't want to fuck this up,
but it looks like it says pop poo pop
popup Hoopa.
The pub Hoopla.
Probably fucking that up,
but this is how it's pronounced.
I know how to spell it.
You look like that one guy that got
arrested for murdering his wife.
Was that,
what was that?
What are you,
that old guy,
Phil Spector and Phil Spector.
Oh,
no,
that wasn't his wife.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's very funny actually.
That's strong it strong.
Remember that guy you show up for court
with these crazy wigs on w was it a wing
or was it actually his hair?
No,
no,
you would wig.
This is,
um,
this is how you spell it.
It's P a.
P.
A.
K.
H.
A pup.
Hookah.
Oh God.
Look at that hair.
Yeah,
that's the same,
I don't even know if the case,
if you don't want announce a kit that's,
he actually turned it to the next level.
Phil Spector,
we're looking at Phil Spector from his
murder trial.
It was a horrible story.
Like Phil Spector.
Specter
stuck a gun in some chick's mouth.
Wow.
And killed her.
And apparently that was a,
something that he had been known to do.
He would,
he would pull a gun sticking in like an
artist's mouth,
you know?
Do you know that there's a lot of people
that think that Jimmy Hendrix manager
killed him?
Yeah.
And apparently there's like a guy who
wrote a book guy who was a bodyguard or
something or another for a,
someone in the music business back then
claimed that that was a,
he wrote,
uh,
wrote a book about this and claims
that's what happened.
That Jimi Hendrix,
a girlfriend at the time jumped off a
building.
She committed suicide and they were
like,
now they threw that girl building.
It's like,
whoa,
what's the dirt?
Wasn't there a documentary or a movie
about it?
Was there,
I think there might've been,
you know,
you hear about a guy like Hendrix had
died at 27 and you go,
Whoa,
what,
how was that?
How was he that good?
How the hell is he had a good at 27.
Okay.
Fuck man.
Imagine if you're still alive.
It would be threatening.
I saw guns and roses,
uh,
like a month ago.
And uh,
earl guide is like right in the front
row.
They played a three and a half hour
show.
It was weird seeing him did it.
Really?
Yeah.
It was weird seeing him perform.
I tell you that slash still has it that
that motherfucker jams three and a half
hours is insane.
Yeah.
What's a normal concert for like
aerosmith or some shit?
Maybe two hours maybe.
Maybe it's a long,
it's a long time.
Three and a half hours if not four
hours.
Six hours.
Can I get seven?
Did I get to heaven?
Well he um,
he like went to the dark lands and then
came back like axl rose's,
a weird guy.
The key,
he vanished and then returned and now
they're killing it.
It's weird.
Remember when he broke his leg and was
singing on stage with a uh,
with a cast on,
on a chair?
Yeah.
It was weird watching him because when
you're that close it's weird seeing
things that you normally wouldn't even
notice.
One thing was after every song he would
just go behind this curtain,
come out with a different shirt on and
he must have changed t shirts maybe like
20 times in outfits.
Like you'd have a com.
I have a scarf on this one and wow.
It's weird.
Yeah.
That's him with a leg brace on.
Singing with a leather jacket on.
Okay.
It's dual.
Pretty bad ass.
Who the fuck's ever done that before?
And I know,
I know Dave Grohl did it while he was
performing acts alone.
Dumb has didn't really?
Yeah,
that's hilarious.
He loaned him his brace.
That's the throne thing.
Oh,
the throne.
He ticks around with them.
How long did axle have to sing on that
thing for a couple of months,
I think.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Girls,
squads,
people.
How amazing it was.
Dave's and that he loaned attack,
so I'm sorry.
Oh,
other way around.
Well that's both bad ass equally bad
ass.
Either way.
You do it either way.
You pop it back and forth.
What were you saying,
Brian?
How bad ass is Dave grohl doubt.
Like he,
he was the drummer for Nirvana and then
totally chicken created the foo fighters
right after Nirvana.
And it's one of the best bands ever,
you know,
and he's now not even playing drums
anymore.
Was he playing drums for Nirvana?
Yeah,
he was the drummer for Nevada and now
he's saying,
well,
you know,
kind of like,
yeah,
I could do anything.
When drummer that you're an guitars of
the year separate,
separate,
separate bands and he's a bad
motherfucker.
Yeah,
for sure.
I love the female writers.
No,
never him once.
I don't think so.
Um,
I met one of the other guys in Nirvana.
Who's the other gentleman?
Uh,
Pat smear or are you got the guy who
flies planes?
I met him at one of the marijuana policy
project,
which basically,
yeah,
that gentleman really guitar up and it
fell and hit him in the head during the
mistakes.
Musical words.
Oh fuck man.
That's terrible.
I remember when the old days when people
would smash guitars on stage.
I was like a big deal.
Trent reznor used to do it every,
I mean,
what the fuck is that about man?
What was that about?
What was this whole destroying musical
instruments thing about [inaudible] man,
we got to break it all down.
How much trash is fucking guitar,
dude,
smash slash fuck.
You didn't have any money.
And you just imagine if you could get
Jimi Hendrix Guitar.
Did he smash guitars?
No.
What do you think?
I got it right here at the first person
to do it,
or at least credited with,
let me think.
1960 so I'm still only hand Jimi Hendrix
burned his guitar.
Yeah,
he burned it.
I'd say the first person wouldn't be
like,
yeah,
I feel like he smashed it to,
I would say he's smashed guitars.
Hidden.
He smash at Jamie.
I don't know that he didn't add up.
I'll look up hendricks just for sure,
but I got the guy that,
the first guy who's got,
who was the first coffee towns in it.
Oh,
of course.
That's right.
Pete towns and do it.
You know what?
I might be fucking this up.
Jimmy Hendrix might not have smashed
guitar.
It might've just been townsend didn't
someone and kiss that ace freely of her
smash guitars.
Here's Monterey pop festival.
Like Jimmy lit it on fire and smashed
it.
Oh Man.
He was high as fuck.
Yeah,
just hitting everything.
Yeah.
Some weak ass lambs.
He got to work on your,
oh no,
I know.
Oh yeah.
He can't move in those fucking pants,
those pants,
man.
These tickets constrict your deck.
So I know these guys had kids.
Lenny Kravitz,
his pants ripped open.
Yeah,
that's right.
Long for [inaudible] death.
Hank can fly.
Jimi Hendrix was,
uh,
he was wearing those,
those are jeans,
like jeans,
that tight man.
You can't do shit in those things.
You definitely can't smash guitars
correctly.
Okay,
so he smashed guitars a bunch of times.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
This has to go to the feeling of the
music you're getting,
man.
You just get into it.
Yeah.
Plus you're on acid,
right?
Yeah.
Also,
he's on acid a lot during this time.
It wasn't any,
wow,
look at this.
They just let him smash these things.
Here's a guitar sacrifice.
So like a guy like Matt,
thea mortal Brown and Jimi Hendrix swing
that guitars like just needs a little
coaching.
He used to like,
that's like a big exercise they use with
macy's and shit.
You know,
that's like hitting tires with
sledgehammers.
That's an excellent form of exercise.
Now try to find nickelback smashing
guitars.
Not going to happen.
Maybe I'm going to be on nickelback.
I don't,
I don't think they're bad but I,
I accept that you don't like it.
I just feel like as I move into 2018 I
want to spend more time positive on
things I like.
Then things I don't like and more time.
If there are things that I don't like,
I want to be able to look at them in a
more relaxed manner and it'd be less,
less engaged with it and more,
more just as long as you're not hurting
anybody,
just have fun.
Who gives a shit?
Do you read about Will Ferrell?
Uh,
he did a uh,
rose parade.
They acted the eight,
he dressed up in a character with this
other girl that used to be on Saturday
night live.
They acted like local,
like news people doing like showing the
parade and they broadcast it live on
Amazon prime and people thought it was
real.
They didn't read.
A lot of people didn't even realize it
was will ferrell.
And so like people are like angry
about it cause they didn't get the joke.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
He shaved his head.
He's got prosthetic on or something.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
That is amazing.
As fictional local TV hosted dual made
jokes about the parades,
marching bands,
flower covered floats and inaccurate
historical uniforms.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
I guess you can get it on Amazon prime
right now.
And I guess there was so many one stars
and all the reviews are like,
how dare they.
This is a tradition.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
These local news people.
That is so funny.
That's so funny.
Will Ferrell's fucking anybody who says
will Ferrell's not funny.
I can't talk to over 1,001
stars on it.
Yeah,
I just can't.
I can't talk to anybody who doesn't
think that guys hilarious.
Yeah,
there's certain,
see I just contradicted what I said
earlier.
You don't have,
you can like whatever you want.
I don't care.
Meanwhile I'm like,
except Will Ferrell.
Fuck for me.
Towel.
Dig In nights,
man,
when he's running around in his
underwear,
he's saying,
Tom Cruise,
use your witchcraft.
I'm crying,
you know,
that's based off a real thing.
If him running out thinking he's on fire
because there was a famous car like,
like what's that petroleum where it's
like,
uh,
you can't see petroleum when it's on
fire at petroleum fire.
It's clear or it's invisible.
And so this famous race car driver.
Yeah.
If there was a fire in his car but you
couldn't see it.
So He's like,
I'm on fire.
But to everyone else it looked like he
was just a crazy person.
I think this might be it.
I see like all these people are on fire
right now and he can't even tell uh,
there there's a fire.
Oh Wow.
Cause Petroleum fire,
you can't see,
Whoa,
what?
Yeah.
Oh my God,
I didn't know that whole seat.
No,
this,
yeah,
you can't not see trillium firing can
only see at night.
Oh my God,
that is insane.
So all these people are on fire and
they're running from invisible fire.
Oh my
God.
How am I just now learning this?
You can't see petroleum fire.
Is that real?
Yeah.
You only at night there has to be really
dark cause it's like this,
the light blue part of it.
Oh my God,
get any orange or anything so fucked.
But how hilarious is it that was based
on a real and so he has flame retardant
clothes on so that stuff doesn't catch
fire.
Right.
This is a skin.
It's getting it.
Oh my God.
How are [inaudible]?
And it got into the crowd too.
Like people are like,
why is everyone freaking out?
Oh here's another radio lab plug.
I was listening this thing about ball
lightning.
I sit here right now,
he'll catch it on fire and uh,
see how much fire,
Ooh.
So that's your nose.
See like right there.
You can't tell it's on fire right there.
Yeah.
That's insane.
That's insane dude.
Oh my God.
He just dropped something in it
instantly caught fire.
Wow.
That's why petroleum fires are a
dangerous for firemen and stuff like
that.
Cause you can't see,
how do I not know that?
I can't believe I woke up today on
January 2nd,
2018 I learned that for the first time.
I should have known that I'm not woke,
not vogue.
That's Hashtag not woke that you're a
Hashtag blessed Hashtag blessed but not
Hashtag woke up today.
I didn't know about petroleum fires.
It's crazy that you could just buy a
lighter.
You know what?
Talk about like what's the possibility
of people being fucked up it way less
than you think because like lighters are
everywhere and this relatively few fires
in comparison to the number of lighters.
You know,
like everybody's got a fucking lighter.
Everybody we know has a lighter and was
the last time someone window let,
let some shit on fire.
Right?
It is weird.
It's weird.
But like the real weirdness about
driving cars is how few accidents there
are.
That's the real weirdness.
Of course,
it's going to be some and more so with
these fucking assholes on their phones.
God Damn.
I've been seeing some drifters.
Some people drift in lanes and texting
while they're driving.
Holy Shit.
That's common.
But take that away.
And it's remarkable how rarely we slam
into each other.
It's remarkable.
You can go years without a car accident
if you're careful.
Years and years and years.
Fuck man.
Can I say in this city?
Yeah,
some remarkable,
but you know they happen.
They definitely happen.
There's no way right now they can tell
exactly what you were doing.
They just know what happened.
But if there's a way that they can put
one of those scent,
you know how they have,
don't they have onstar now and a lot of
cars you buy him like from the factory
and they have that onstar thing where
you,
you could actually like have comp calls,
like make phone calls with the whatever
it is on the other line.
Like you could say,
hey can you book me a reservation at
restaurant?
Like they're also monitoring how fast
your car's going.
They're monitoring like certain certain
metrics,
certain things they could figure out
like what happened when you were causing
an accident?
Where'd you go?
Where'd you drive to?
Like if they could track you and GPS and
at a certain point in time they're going
to be like,
why can't we just film him?
This is going to film you all the time
inside your car.
And like if you want to drive a
cadillac,
don't have any fucking orgies in it
cause it's great cause we have to film
you because otherwise we're never going
to know what the fuck you did to cause
his car accident.
We don't want to get sued.
Ultima bail is the ultimate bill has the
camera.
So like if you're doing the lane
departure setting,
it detects if you're not paying
attention.
So then by tracking your face,
so there's a camera and I think it's
oldsmobiles now.
Wow.
Well that's sort of like the iphone x or
10 right?
It sees your face,
recognize your face to open up your a
password and it works pretty fucking
good.
It's not perfect,
but it's like whoa.
It's a lot better than I thought it was
going to be a lot smoother.
I got this phone when I couldn't find my
glasses and I found them the other day
and I have a beard now and add a
stocking hat on,
still unlocks it.
It's like how the hell does it go
through all those things.
What would change if someone gained or
lost weight?
Would anything change?
I don't think so.
I think the texts like how far your eyes
are a part,
you know,
and like little things like that.
Like I think my,
what's weird is I have a Amazon Echo in
my next to my bed now cause it's like
the best alarm clock average.
Like it's one of those things where you
go like Alexa,
you know,
and uh,
but it has a camera on it.
Yeah.
It's watching them for sure.
Nice.
Is watching your your whole life.
I'm like keep an eye on me Alexa.
Every time you beat off Alexa makes a
checkmark right next to you.
It is weird though.
Like we'll be just sleeping all the
night and Alexa will just be like,
I can't understand what you're talking
about.
And you're like,
well I didn't say anything.
Luxembourg.
She'll just start coming to life.
She's starting to wake up,
she's becoming more woke.
To me the best is if you go Alexa rap
and does this wrap,
it's could do a wrap and it's a good
rap.
Yeah.
We were talking before the podcast,
there was a,
uh,
it's a good rap.
We were talking before the podcast is
there was something about an apple
buying Netflix when Jesus,
yeah.
How do you feel about a company that
gets that big?
Like how do you feel about like any
company that does a buys up everything,
you know,
they just,
Disney,
Disney bought up star wars.
What else?
They buy out.
Didn't they just buy the other movie
studio owns,
uh,
the avengers or whatever.
A pmr.
Paramont I dunno.
I don't know if there were a lot of
money.
$52 billion to buy 21st century.
Yeah.
So now like the Marvel Universe is
complete I think now is it bad?
Is it bad to have giant companies?
Some people would say yes.
Right?
What about a giant company?
Like Google seems to be a pretty God
damn good company.
Like as far as like the way they treat
people,
it's supposed to be like pretty good.
Other than that James Damore memo thing,
that the thing that went out,
remember that that whole,
uh,
where the guy was talking about why
there aren't women in tech and what
would encourage them.
And a lot of people said he was sexist
and it got crazy and I was like,
then I had to read it like a couple of
times ago.
It's like one or two things.
It might be misconstrued as being sexist
because of the term neuroticism and he,
I think he believes,
I believe he uses the term neurotic but
really super duper controversial fucking
thing and although I don't agree with
it,
Google firing the guy,
I kind of get it.
I get where they are just to kind of
calm everyone's nerves.
I don't,
I don't agree with that at all,
but I understand why they as a
corporation would think that way,
but for the most part I seem to,
I like what they're doing.
Like they're,
they're buying up all these robotics and
these different corporations that are
creating the google.
Didn't Google buy up Boston
dynamics already sold it though.
Yeah,
they sold it.
They bought it and then sold it.
Still all the secrets.
Interesting.
I wonder if that's what they do because
you don't hear about the sale when they
get rid of something like that.
Yeah.
Purchase requisite.
You sell it and then you make sure that
you don't sign some sort of uh,
you know,
noncompete clause and could have often
done it to buy a purse and there
might've been someone working there they
wanted to have on their team.
And so they just,
ah,
well by your whole company now you work
for us.
Whoa,
that's some fucking game of thrones type
shit with silicone.
Disney was smart,
Dubai,
Hulu because they just pulled all their
stuff off and Netflix,
all Disney,
I think Disney often flood and now
they're just going to put it all on
Hulu,
which is awesome cause I left Hulu.
But here's the thing,
question,
like is that,
is it,
is it possible to be as big as Google
and not be scary?
Right.
And when something gets so big that the
controls so much,
people like tend to just immediately get
wary.
Like whoa,
like this is the whole market,
right?
If there's only one way you can get the
Internet for verizon was the only
Internet provider on planet earth,
that's it.
We'd be like,
Hey,
that just you,
just you.
So if that's that because it's too big,
right.
Controls too much.
It's like what's the level we're
comfortable with apple,
with apple?
It depends on the company also,
I think,
you know,
like I think a lot of people trust
Google and apple.
Apple put the nets over the buildings
when the people were jumping and did the
right thing.
She didn't think with the batteries they
did the response.
I got to see that battery thing is
crazy.
We got to talk about that.
How many years ago did we start talking
about who called?
You called it in like whatever the first
year of the fucking knew it was when
they had a new iphone and then the new,
uh,
new new iphone.
As soon as the new new iphone came out,
you
were like,
I know what these mother fuckers are
doing.
Yeah.
But I get their excuse and it wasn't
like,
yeah,
to lock.
It might've been like two I phones and I
want to be honest about this.
I don't remember.
But I remember there was a time that you
called it first way before everybody
else.
I was like,
Brian's all paranoid about technology.
I understand their excuse.
So I get what they're saying.
I mean there,
if the batteries are going to start
failing because it's,
you can't have the is all fucked up in a
battery.
But to deny that they know that the
throttling down of performance of the
phone's not going to influence people
into deciding,
deciding to buy a new phone is
ridiculous.
Yeah,
you are.
You are literally disabling the phone.
You're,
and you're not doing your customer
service base.
You're not doing them a service.
Because if you were,
if you really cared about them getting
the best stuff all the time,
what you would do is he would say,
Hey,
um,
these batteries are going to get older.
If you want to continue your phones,
here's a new battery to reasonable rate
other wise,
we have to throttle down the performance
of your phone so that you can get a
day's use out of it.
But that can be avoided by simply
swapping out the battery.
So this is what happens when your phone
gets to be a year old yet
that,
that's sort of disingenuous.
Right.
And the batteries were so expensive.
Now I think they got them down to $29
but that's just in response to getting
in this situation right now.
I think they make amazing shit.
This iphone 10 x,
whatever the fuck they want to call it.
It's amazing.
It's like,
it's crazy that there's a company that
makes something like that.
They're going to make some mistakes.
I don't know who approved that mistake,
but that's a mistake.
They shouldn't have done that.
But the stuff they make is,
it's someone's got to do that.
It's not going to be like the Brian and
Joe Corporation.
Right.
You know?
I mean you need something with massive
resources and a ton of shit fuck ton of
people to be able to put together the
cash to make an iphone 10 I mean this,
you got to hire a lot of fucking people
to make this thing right.
You got a higher wizards and sorcerers
and God damn silicone geniuses and
people know how to get lithium ion
batteries thinner than your fucking
fingernail in these things.
Nothing in your fingernail.
Right at the end of that,
a finger.
What's like,
how thick is a,
well,
it can't be that thick.
The shit has a case on it.
Like how thin is a a battery and a cell
phone?
It's a pretty thin like paper chip or a
potato chip rather like a flat potato.
If you ever could flatten out a potato
chip,
it's a little thicker than that.
Actually.
What's crazy though is that I,
the the phone before this iphone seven
plus s whatever the fuck it was,
when we owe debt,
when I download the new operating system
on it,
it was crashy.
It was buggy.
It fucked up all the time.
But then when I got the iphone x,
the same operating system,
it worked way better.
So that's like not anything to do with
the battery,
you know,
that's just because they build an
operating system around this processor
and this screen and all the components
on this and then they're emulating it
for all the other phones,
you know,
or whatever they're doing.
It's almost like
the only way to be truly awesome at
something.
That's just to be greedy too.
It's like they got to have like,
we'll get a fuel this motherfucker.
Okay,
okay.
This is,
this is projected,
uh,
sales and we can get that up to about
20%.
And this is how we're going to do it.
Do you have the dark secret meetings
where they can just add candles?
Went into the fucking basement.
Nicole,
we're to slow down the old phones.
No,
don't do it.
Mark watching for technology.
We've always worked for technology and
we can't slow down the fucking phones,
man.
We're gonna slam down vessel.
I'm down selling the new shit.
They don't need the new shit.
Okay.
It's about information more than it's
about new apps.
You've been watching Black Mirror.
I only watched three episodes,
but I love it.
You haven't watched the new season of
watched.
Uh,
I think one episode in the new season,
which was the video game episode,
but the guy was in the life video game
that was remarkably similar to Arusha
fears.
Salvia divinorum trip.
I was done no new season as of like two
days ago.
Here's another new days ago.
Oh,
I know.
I can't,
I don't have the time for this.
Uh,
but the,
the last one I watched was the video
game one.
Um,
I'm hooked on the unbreakable Kimmy
Schmidt right now on Netflix.
Have you watched it?
Dude?
That is a funny,
silly show.
Oh yeah,
I have seen that.
Yeah.
The lady,
she was trapped in a bunker for 15 years
for in a religious cult and she gets out
and she's living in New York City and
she doesn't know what the fuck's going
on.
It's really funny,
man.
There's a couple of episodes were kind
of falls apart,
but then it bounces back strong.
It's very funny again now.
It's a really good show.
I'm on like episode,
uh,
I want to say eight.
I think I'm on episode eight.
Black Mirror is getting into some
trouble cause I guess Carl,
you know Carl pink pig crow.
Pinkerton.
Yeah.
Supposedly two things.
I am two different episodes.
He talks about something that they stole
in Black Mirror and ou,
which is weird.
It was in the news today.
Um hmm.
Well,
I don't know what the specifics are,
so I don't want to comment,
but um,
there's a lot of things that black
mirror did his subjects that I talked
about too,
but it was just because a lot of people
were talking about potential future
technologies,
like this video game thing where they
put something in the back of your head,
like the Matrix and plug you into some
artificial experience that's
indistinguishable.
That's what those,
I've talked about that a hundred times
just from being high,
you know,
and thinking about what are they going
to be able to do next that's crazier
than a Duncan trussell when he had that
htc vive,
you put that thing on.
Did you put the thing on I halfway?
Oh,
you have one?
Yeah.
Dunkin.
A hangover is podcasts and I put it off
for like an hour and a half before I did
it.
We,
you do just do you do that and you go,
okay,
well what's next?
You know,
so I don't know if Carl just was able to
figure out what's next or are they
saying this plagiarism?
Yeah.
I mean if,
if,
uh,
if the,
you have the article,
Jamie,
if,
uh,
it seems pretty specific where it's not
like,
hey,
let's tease talking about simulation.
Teary.
It's more like,
oh,
he actually had this idea.
I forget what it is.
I saw it this morning.
Sometimes though it is parallel
thinking.
So let's just in the interest of this
spoiler alerts in there,
I don't even want to read.
Okay,
well watch Karl Pink and predict new
Black Mirror plots years ahead of time.
Yeah,
you're right.
We can't,
we can't bring these out.
So,
uh,
who,
who wrote the article,
what's it on?
Gizmodo.
I love that.
Very good site.
Yeah.
And gadgets.
Very good sight.
He real news.
Do you have like five websites that you
just shuffle back and forth?
Like,
like Gizmodo is one in gadgets when
Kotaku is one.
I just signed this one who scientist.
People get mad,
but I like to read the New York Times.
New York Times.
He would get mad.
You're like read fake news.
It's the fucking New York Times.
Okay.
You cannot just immediately dismissed
the fucking New York Times.
You cannot with any mistakes that
anybody has made ever.
You cannot fucking dismiss the New York
Times.
How dare you.
They're a giant part of what made people
at this level in terms of our
understanding of world events,
a giant part leading to 2017 like if you
look at the history of human beings,
understanding the reality of a,
a detailed intellectual understanding of
the reality of certain current world
events compiled in a daily resource.
The New York Times change the world.
It offered people super high level
information from Uber Smart people on a
regular basis and to dismiss that and
say that that's just as good as any
other papers that no,
no,
no.
There's a is a pursuit.
What they were in,
they were in a pursuit for excellence in
information.
Now,
whether or not they've made some
mistakes to,
I criticized him for that.
Conor mcgregor weird thing that they
said is his face was covered in blood
and he was,
and they fixed it immediately.
Yeah.
They said he'd be almost fell
through the ropes before the rescue.
The referee rescued them like,
I won't eat it.
You don't have to.
He got his ass kicked.
You have to make anything up like that.
What happened was amazing.
You don't have to embellish it just to
make your magazine.
This is crazy.
Like you can't do that.
You're the New York Times,
like in,
especially in this day and age,
you got to resist and you gotta be,
I'm rubber.
You're glue.
You can't even respond.
You can't and you can't put out anything
fake.
You just can't,
you know?
But people that go,
oh,
the New York Times is fake news.
Like they've been around for so long.
Do you know how much important shit they
put out?
If you're going to just dismiss them
because you love trump,
is that you're really willing to do
that.
That's,
that's as crazy as anything I've ever
heard.
You can't do that.
Like they can't be exonerated.
I mean,
they can be exonerated,
but they can't be exempt from not being
called out by printing something.
That's not true.
They,
everyone should be held up the same
standards.
But if you don't appreciate what the,
The New York Times has done,
that seems crazy to me.
It's just they're really important.
Could you see all the trump like global
warming tweets?
Like he doesn't really understand global
warming.
He's trolling scientist wake up freezing
right now.
Global warming's not real.
He's 70 and he's,
he's trolling.
Yeah.
It's weird,
right?
It's true.
I wish the whole thing was a trawl.
That'd be so fucking know.
He's trolling about that though.
You know,
he just doesn't want anybody fucking
with them and he feels like a lot of the
mainstream media,
they fuck with them.
And so he fires back and then it becomes
this weird thing where all the people
that are on his side started like they,
you know,
they pick people,
pick sides man.
And they're like fake news food news.
Like,
no,
it's The New York Times.
It's not.
It's the one of the best news sources
ever have.
They said,
shit,
that's not true.
100% you know why they're run by people.
People fuck up everywhere.
There's not a place where they go where
they don't fuck up every fucking place a
person goes.
They fuck up.
They fuck up in Harvard,
they fuck up in mit.
They just fuck up way less than most of
us.
There's still just people.
Okay.
Since W it's weird time right now.
So we're weird time right now as far as
uh,
the way people are looking at things,
you know,
just seems everything's,
it seems very exaggerated.
A group preparing for something like
we're screaming baby war North Korea,
North Korea.
But here's the other thing,
North Korea just made a speech recently
where they were actually open to high
level talks and there were,
there are,
there are more.
It was way more passive and less
threatening.
Yeah.
And people like this crazy motherfucker
might realize trump is a crazy
motherfucker too,
who actually runs the u s and unlike
Obama who would probably never consider
a attacking North Korea,
he's looking at trump.
He's like,
this dude is 70.
Okay,
he's old as fuck.
He's been a gangster his whole life.
And now he just took over the country
and he left the military guys do
whatever the fuck they want to do.
You don't think there's a high
possibility that some of those
spaceships from Nevada might come out of
a hole in the ground and go rocketing
towards North Korea in 20 minutes and
let loose some crazy new bombs that you
haven't even heard of yet.
That's entirely possible.
He knows it.
I don't like to think there's any
benefit to our current situation.
Well,
we offer just cut off all their with a
gas.
Yeah.
There's some serious sanctions,
so that might be why he's telling you
guys.
Right.
That's actually probably more logical.
Yeah,
but I'm doing more of
the comic book thing.
It's like people don't want to piss
trump off.
It's interesting,
you know?
Yeah,
it makes sense.
He's like,
he's definitely nuttier than the regular
dude.
He's definitely not nothing other than
the regular dude that's in the job.
I thought we were getting an attack the
other day when that space x launch
happen,
like that was,
well,
everyone at starbucks,
I said starbucks,
everyone at starbucks started running
out and I was like,
oh my God,
what's going on?
Like is there a bomb?
Like I was kind of freaked out.
Then everyone's like staring at the sky
so I run out and first I thought it was
an alien because I that pulsating smoke
that was happening on the side,
like I'd never seen anything like that
before.
It was like,
wait my eyes,
I've never seen that before because it
was like,
it looked like a big whale.
Then there was like a.in
the middle of it that was pulsating,
like smoke rings almost and it just
looked foreign.
It looked like an alien,
but then everyone's like,
is that Korea?
And I'm like,
I didn't even think about North Korea.
Like is that headed downtown?
I saw one of those ones
melrose,
it was a a launch at Edwards air force
base.
They launched something like some
missile test.
I was like,
Whoa,
you saw this thing shooting across the
sky.
People are pulling their cars over.
This is a long time ago.
And they did it like right at dusk,
right as the sun was setting and they
shot.
I think they thought they'd get away
with it.
They could sneak it in there before we
could see it.
It's,
it's weird that they do that.
Like there was a lot of car accidents
when that happened because everyone
thought,
what the fuck?
Where are we getting attack?
It's weird that they don't like,
you know how your phone goes off if
Pablo gets kidnapped by his Stepdad,
you know you have that,
the android,
but they want to say,
hey,
there's going to be a big rocket launch.
Jamie,
what does this the one from last week?
Ah,
look at their dish.
That is crazy.
Oh my God.
And it's,
it's going around the earth and off
into,
fuck,
it's shooting off three on Friday night.
So just,
here's your warning.
Don't forget fries.
Oh,
we're going to be sure.
When is the one where um,
he shoots a tesla to Mars.
When's he doing that?
It's coming up soon.
I think that's what the thing on Friday.
It was supposed to got pushed from
Friday to Friday,
from Thursday and it's setting up the
next,
the big launch,
which I think is that word.
Has there ever been a god?
It's more like Tony Stark.
Then you on musk.
Never.
He's awesome.
You think he's sending his car away so
he can go get it?
Like he's going to be the first one out
of here.
Take my car with me.
I won't let them go.
You got to stay.
Do we need you down here?
You might not make it back.
What if your calculations are off?
Like you know sometimes people were
saying they get up the Tesla and the
door handle doesn't open up
automatically and then you don't even
have a door handle like,
okay,
what if that happens when you're up
there bro?
Yeah.
Huh?
Never.
We never had a super genius that
everybody wants to just hand the keys to
before.
What if he is the Bitcoin guy too?
That some people think,
some people think he created bitcoin.
Yeah.
Shit.
I have to ask Mr Antonopoulos if he
agrees with that.
I don't believe that.
That's why don't you?
Because that would be too crazy.
He could have been done a two crazy
what?
He's an alien.
What if he's the future?
He's dating Johnny Depp's acts.
He can't be too close.
Broke up with her bro.
Go for him.
He brought it to the comic store one
night.
Oh,
that's right dude.
I gotta think
that there's levels to everything and
they might be even levels in the super
genius category and he's in some weird
new,
crazy ultra productive level of the
super genius category.
Did he,
he powered what,
what part of New Zealand was at or
something like that with that gigantic,
was it Australia?
It was Australia.
He made some sort of a bet where he
would install some mega battery complex
in Australia.
Am I remembering this right?
And uh,
it worked perfectly in record time.
See,
Tesla built a giant battery to fight
power outages in Australia and it's
already working and it worked in like
milliseconds.
Like the power went down and it kicked
on in milliseconds only last three years
before it starts at 0.14
seconds.
That's insane.
After a major plant,
the Loy Yang sang a station in the
neighboring state of Victoria suffered a
sudden drop in output.
That's amazing.
It kicked in just 0.14
seconds after the thing went out.
The thing.
Nothing.
Yeah,
man.
He's a wizard.
He's,
he's some sort of new type of a cultural
figure like the,
the Electronic Daddy.
He's the guy's making cars.
He's going to build autonomous.
Uh,
what are those a transporter trucks.
Gigantic semi trucks.
The boring company.
Yeah,
the boring company.
He's going to fix traffic.
Why is it just keeps going?
Why is he a tackle?
Things like cancer.
Herpes figured out on your own bit.
Busy making electric cars.
The fuck.
What do you,
why don't you fix it?
I'm doing this.
I made a car.
I'm shooting one of my cars to the Mars.
You want to come when to watch?
I think he's got like,
he's got to have two or three friends
that are sort of like,
what do you guys want to do this month?
What are we going to fix or fuck with?
Or He's too smart to have friends.
He's got a couple of people that he
observes.
It's got to have a buddy.
He bounces some shit off of it as an
alien.
You don't think the buddy would go,
just talk to Johnny Depp.
If you got a real buddy,
I'd be like,
listen,
seems amazing.
And who she's probably telling the
truth.
I don't know.
I don't know who's right,
who's wrong.
Well,
I just,
I want you to be happy bro.
I don't want craziness.
And you like,
she just got off of doing coke and
jumping out of windows and Harris
freaking out.
What do I do?
Yeah,
I,
uh,
there's levels to the super genius game
and he's some new level.
He's like some new,
uh,
Mike Tyson Punch out character.
Like,
Whoa,
like this is the new super genius
inventor level,
but that's also a super famous person.
Like everybody knows who Elon Musk is.
He's almost like a character.
Like if you wanted proof that there's
some sort of a really super complex but
captivating narrative about being a
person 2018 he's a central character.
Was He smart?
His whole life?
Like was,
he's creating things in like middle
school and high score digital.
One day out of nowhere,
this guy comes back.
Oh,
I invented it itself.
Stuff.
Yeah,
I'm smart.
That's a good question.
Maybe it is all off rouge.
It's a good question.
It's really just foxconn.
What if he's the first robot?
What if they sent him to like we,
we get him a run for president.
He went and then,
uh,
on TV cuts open his arm and he shows you
circuitry.
It's like,
robots need love too.
I helped you guys a fixture,
whole fucking world.
That's the way
he made a computer game when he was 12.
Dao,
te normal doom,
doom,
vr.
Have you played that?
Yeah.
It's very disturbing to know those
people that have that much smarter than
you.
Right?
And you go,
well,
right?
Being,
here's the thing,
like
people are better than you at shit.
You got to get over that.
There's just no way around it.
You know?
Imagine if you like Elon Musk's older
brother and you,
you know,
you're like,
Bro,
you don't know shit.
You're only seven.
And he's like,
okay.
It just brews up inside of them.
Grows,
grows in power.
Then what do you do?
Even if you're happy,
even when you have a great life,
like even if you're like,
you know,
what do I do?
Oh,
um,
I make log furniture,
you know,
like for outside for the patio.
I mean some of the people's fondest
moments you're sitting on the back patio
and um,
I just,
it seems kind of old fashioned to me and
one of the old fashioned things that I
like,
his log furniture,
so I build log outside patio furniture.
My Name's Michael.
Michael Mosque.
Yeah.
I'm super happy.
Couldn't be happier.
Yeah.
He's my brother.
Ha Ha.
Yeah.
You line,
he's a,
let me tell you something.
Elan's on speed.
Okay.
He lands on adderall and provigil and
nuvigil and he's taking micro doses.
He microdosing he's not clean test him
shit.
He's got a brother Kimbal Musk,
elon musk.
He's a super genius that exists in the
Lotus position.
Floats in midair and some wheat silo
somewhere in New Hampshire.
And they go visit them a couple of times
a month.
I wouldn't mind,
I would be like,
give me a free test every couple of
days.
They probably got that dude in the
bunker with Dick Cheney right now.
Kimbal musk.
Yeah.
I want to know what Kimble does.
He teaches Kung Fu.
He's in those videos that are always
posted on instagram.
He's just imagine if his brother was
just a nut.
Oh look at him.
Handsome bastard shrinking coffee.
Oh my age.
45 regional manager for blockbuster
video.
Oh,
he's from South Africa.
Even crazier.
So Ellen's from South Africa to wow.
If they could have started at a company
called Zip two and sold it to compaq and
that's where he started.
South Africa is a interesting place.
Very,
very interesting place.
A lot of people I know that go there,
love it.
And I'm obviously the crazy history with
Nelson Mandela and apartheid and how
recent that was to us.
But I always think of a,
that sugar man movie.
When I think of South Africa now,
I always think of district nine.
Doesn't it look like district nine
there?
Um,
the movie with the robots standard or
no?
No,
district nine was the movie with the
aliens are aliens.
No,
they weren't robots.
Right.
They were like weird aliens.
What were they?
I think some,
that sort of thing of both.
Honestly.
It was like some sort of tech alien.
Oh,
that's right.
Can you show it again?
That was a great fucking movie.
I love that.
Maybe it's one of my favorites.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
They were like some sort of Matt
goodness.
Yeah,
that's right,
man.
Fuck.
That was a good move.
A to rewatch it.
I think it was shot in South Africa.
I think that's where he's from.
They've got it made it neill.
Blomkamp.
Yeah.
Um,
what was the movie I said that it made
me remind me of,
uh,
what did I just say?
Didn't eat.
I heard it,
but it's not registered.
I don't,
God dammit.
Yeah.
Aye d aunt word is always a big
connection.
I always think about them,
but I was saying it was Nelson Mandela.
There was something else that made me
think about South Africa.
I'll come back to it.
Oh,
that Alysia movie.
That was the Matt Damon Movie.
Was that in South Africa?
Yes.
I think it's sort of similar topic as
district nine.
Yeah.
Day Man.
It's crazy that a guy like elon musk's,
something super duper fucking genius
would come out of that spot.
And what's that plays like let's do a
jre in South Africa to alive.
Jre cause one with the great whites.
Fuck that.
That's true.
Right?
That's a scary spot.
Like I'm here.
When you fly over me and you're playing,
they jump up and try to bite the plane
that's bought man.
You want to talk about spots South
Africa like Dutch colonists trying to
like carve out a place in the,
in the,
in the land in Africa.
What do you got me here?
The boys in South Africa.
Oh No.
Gotten a zebra suit and went out and but
lions fuck with them.
We had Steve O on the kill Tony last
night for the weigh ins.
Is this an a game preserve though as I
remember them?
Hey actually telling a story on here.
I think that the shot the line part here
and La,
the reason why I ask is there's plays
they have placed in South Africa where
they let the lions loose or not.
Like they,
they know when to let them loose.
Like it's kind of a,
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
The lions actually tried to get him.
Yeah.
Oh No.
Oh my God.
That's insane.
The lions took away their hat.
The Zebra head,
dude,
that is so crazy.
They're lucky they lived,
they did the dumbest stuff on that show.
Yeah.
That really was,
he's had more than one experiences with
lines then because I thought the one
that he had in the tree was the only one
he ever had.
Does that Steevo right there,
that Brit,
he's crazy.
I had drinks with him.
Everlast Eddie Bravo want to 80 students
and uh,
steve o's girlfriend were all hanging
around and um,
steve was telling me like all these
different things that he's about to do.
And I was like,
why?
I'm like,
why are you doing that?
He's showing me the scars that he had on
his arm from the operations where he had
to,
uh,
what's going on here?
She's got a book,
he's Bait for shark.
He put a hook to his lip and then jumped
out in the water with sharks that,
oh my God,
no cage just jumped in the water with a
hook in his mouth.
His latest one where he got burnt his
back and everything.
Yeah,
that's what I'm talking about.
He,
um,
he had a bunch of different,
uh,
skin graphs from cadavers.
That's so crazy that he looks good now
though.
So I'm last night.
He does.
He's shown him,
put him,
he's planning on more chaos.
He's not like you always going to go.
You're done.
You're fine.
You could walk.
Everything's fine.
Let's just end this.
Nope.
It's like evil knievel.
That guy never stopped.
Right.
I think he's way less busted up and evil
knievel evil knievel lived in the days
where,
you know,
they,
the medicine was not as good,
but he also was flying motorcycles and
shit.
Wait,
different weight,
evil knievel was jumping rockets across
canyons.
Remember that?
Snake River Canyon,
is that what it was?
Where was that?
In Arizona or some shit.
What do you remember that he had a
rocket.
He shot across a canyon.
Yeah.
Those,
uh,
those guys that climb those uh,
skyscrapers and stuff.
Did you see the guy that fell that was
this creepy video to watch horrifying
video to watch?
Scary.
Horrifying.
Yeah.
That,
that's um,
encouraging that is not wise,
but discouraging it.
I've seen a lot of those videos.
Right.
I've watched a lot of them.
I had a,
what is his name?
Okay.
Could we have in the show super strong
fingers.
James Kingston,
King James Kingston,
who was a very nice guy who has done a
lot of things online that it freaked me
the fuck out and he was really nice guy.
I don't want to tell that guy.
He can't do something that I enjoyed
watching that he succeeded in doing.
I don't,
I don't want them to land on me either.
You know,
it's like,
I mean,
how much time and effort have you done
in to cleaning up the bottom area where
you might fall because you're going to
fall if you fall out.
Okay.
I'm not saying you're going to fall,
but if you fall you might fall on
somebody.
Okay,
this is different.
Fuck this.
This is not good
for me.
I can't even know why I came in.
A Lot's changed.
Don't put this off.
Oh gotta get down.
We've got to get down from here.
We gotta get that back.
Got To get done
del slow and they'll stop.
Don't do work at the top.
We got away with it.
Just thinking it's not in the interest
of full disclosure.
We got way too high before the show who
legal weed.
That's why you know what it is.
Um,
also that,
um,
that fucking,
the weed that we used to have before
sober October and the weed after sober
October is different,
different stuff.
And I think the combination of those two
things,
a combination of taking a month off and
then trying some new different stuff.
There's different stuff.
It's different.
Yeah.
But your tolerance also restarted.
It's not good right now.
Sketchy.
You gotta be careful.
I've got to gingerly,
gingerly walked into the waters one
month.
Cleanses you.
Oh yeah.
It cleanses you.
It's amazing how fast it cleanses.
Like three days.
If I haven't smoked in three days and I
spoke a joint,
I'm like so stoned out of my gourd.
I still can't remember what I wanted to
say about South Africa.
I knew it had something to do with a
apartheid and the struggle in that area
and how strange it is.
African itself.
What's that?
Chappy chappy.
Oh,
there was another movie and has a decent
word one.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
That wasn't as good.
Deanna word came out strong.
They're interesting that Yolanda,
Yolanda,
Yolanda foster.
How do you say her name?
Oh,
lanny.
How'd he say it?
I think it's your lanny.
Yolanda.
Visser.
That's it.
Yolandi visser reminds me of like,
Bingo.
Yeah.
What movie was that?
Chappy?
Hmm.
Do you know that day?
Uh,
they were like,
you know,
they're like the main characters in the
movie,
but they said something or they to the,
about the director or the studio.
They did,
they got in a fight.
So they took them off the poster and
everything.
That's why they're not on any of the
posters,
even though they're like main
characters.
Fortunate.
Yeah.
That sucks.
See,
that's why people like Deanwood,
they're little too raw.
They need like a,
um,
a slick talking manager and we're doing,
we're,
we're dealing with artists here.
Ultimately they don't really mean what
they say.
It's just the same explosive nature that
lives inside.
Then let some create such amazing music
that you're a fan of and I'm a fan off.
Sometimes it gets haywire and he would
just like to come in and apologize for
bitch slapping you,
telling you to suck his dick was all
wrong.
Yeah.
They,
I mean they didn't even market it.
That dmt word was in it.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
that seems like a mistake.
It seems like you don't like money,
but who knows?
Who knows what they're really like,
you know,
that would be the big bummer.
Right?
You meet him in their dicks mean and
hung out with them.
It really smelled like armpits.
Who's armpits though?
Some people's armpits smell lovely.
It's like that one year you took
deodorant.
It wasn't a whole year.
It's like a week to seem like it here.
Cause like Ari's DMT trip.
I remember what the e three and you're
just making waves of smell.
You can't do that.
You just can't not wear deodorant.
I tried for a little while.
It's weird.
Isn't it interesting too that we've all
just accepted that we have to put
chemicals on certain parts of our body
in order not to smell after you've been
moving around for too long.
It's weird man.
Like have you ever shave your armpits
once by mistake?
Bad idea.
I wonder how much of a effect it must
have some effect on what your armpits
smell like.
How's too?
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
But you can't do it unless you're,
unless you're a bodybuilder.
Like there's things you could do.
Like if my chest itches,
I'll shave my chest and I'm,
I'm embarrassed to say it but I'll do
it.
Especially if it gets itchy after a
while.
I don't fuck with my armpits bro.
That's vain.
Guys.
Shaved their arms that don't have like
something like carrot top or someone
saying he shaves his arms.
Yes.
Does it cause he likes the hate the
field.
Well,
carrot top used to be a super
bodybuilder Jack Guy.
I remember him.
I think he said he'd just,
he did at one time when he was a swimmer
and he just liked to feelings.
It's just like fuck,
slippery,
slippery through that pool slipping.
Sliding.
I oil up,
oil up for I swim.
So he's not buff anymore.
He's back to normal.
Well he's still buff.
He's just not a giant bodybuilder guy.
Creepy buff.
He,
I don't want to talk for him cause I
don't know him but I know Dunkin did
something with him a long time ago.
They did a pilot for some sort of a
reality show.
That's right.
Um,
yeah,
that's the carrot top.
It is Jackie.
Jackie just and that's like a normal
karyotype.
Yeah,
that's,
I think it's more,
he's like,
now he's like more like looks fit.
Okay.
That Kathy Green.
Yeah.
But like back then he looked like super
duper jacked.
Like his shoulders were popping out
unnaturally wide.
Like it didn't even make sense.
Like right there.
Yeah,
he went off the deep end.
It looked like he had me mean.
He's so big.
Who knows what the fuck he was doing,
what he was doing.
A lot of shit that's shorter.
It's not,
look,
it looks like an implants.
Yeah.
It could be,
um,
something called synthol that um,
some bodybuilders,
uh,
engage in and what it does,
they think it helps them balance out
areas of their body that aren't big
enough.
And it's real weird cause there's a ton
of videos of people taking,
you know,
the videos he's putting synthol in their
muscles and dancing around.
That's not that,
that's just him looking buff.
That doesn't look anything nearly as
bad.
We're looking at a carrot top where he
can see his dick route.
It goes to the photo,
goes all the way down as well.
I call what I call it.
So it's my name and Amy Cook always
posting guys.
Exactly what I,
um,
describe that look to people where a man
has his underwear at the very base of
his cock.
That's your Dick Route.
That's a beautiful term.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I,
by the way,
I demand 100% credit for Dick rude
tickers.
I created it.
So I was trying to figure out how to
describe what was uncomfortable about
those kinds of pictures.
And it's like you're trying so hard and
like that's Dick Route.
That's Dick route all the way.
Carrot top.
Take any dignity Dick.
It looks like case a thong on.
It doesn't even look like it shouldn't
be possible with the laws of gravity.
It looks like that things should fall
down your ankles.
Freckled boners she'd come rocketing at
the screen like a three d shark in jaws
three d three but he's,
he's just jacked.
I mean,
he's just a guy who wants everybody suck
his deck.
Just like letting you know it's right
there.
Right there.
That makes sense.
But I mean,
but he's just jack,
that makes sense.
But what does it make sense as the s the
people would stick the oil in their arms
and they would create like water
balloons where their muscles should be
and they would dance around and there's
one video of a guy like throwing punches
in the air with these water balloons for
arms.
It's so weird.
It's just,
it's so strange.
Dick root.
Remember that does a bunch of people
that have those pictures.
It was Dick route pictures.
Didn't cook.
Put like loves the Dick.
Rick,
he's a handsome fellow.
I suppose she has a good works hard in
the gym.
I have to show the goods.
Oh No,
this guy,
100% is using that stuff for,
he's got two equally sized tumors cause
he think that looks good while he's
probably mentally deficient and it's
probably something wrong with them.
Like
God now.
Yeah.
Now if he was like balancing on top of a
skyscraper at the same time would be
even worse.
See the thing about this young man is,
you know,
it was probably something severely wrong
with him,
but what he is is an abuser look at him
throwing punches.
Like he's like some sort of a boxer
character with this giant water balloon
arms,
but he's an abuser of something.
How many people are,
uh,
a more reasonable user of it and use it.
And that's what somebody thought that
the carrot top stuff was,
it's real common.
Yeah.
He's um,
powerful arm wrestled guy has one arm.
It's way more Jack.
Yeah.
That can't be good for you bro.
That's real.
Yup.
He smashes people in arm wrestling.
It's so crazy like,
come on man.
What is that?
Don't do that dude.
He's probably going to be hurting when
he gets older.
We were at yesterday.
Brian might know because he's likes this
topic.
Have you heard of the Korean Hawk guy
that's supposedly dating Lindsay Lohan?
Yeah.
Right now all of a sudden it shows tmz.
Jamie jumps in with relationship gossip.
You son of a bitch.
That's what you do every time.
Well,
they posted a photo last night,
Jamie,
and you know she's dealing with the irs,
right
guys,
super jacked.
Holy Shit.
Look at this dog.
He's living with a werewolf that's like
a monkey werewolf.
I tell you man,
I love Korean.
Uh,
we had a family dinner for my girlfriend
the other day and I come in and they're
cupping or doing that thing where they,
they like picture a little and then they
put these glasses and they pretty much
suck the bad blood out of you.
So I walk in and there's just blood
everywhere and towels and,
and,
and shit like that.
What is it supposed to do?
It's supposed to.
We've talked about this before,
right?
It's supposed to some accelerate blood
flow to the area,
like polls,
the tissue,
the skin away from it and accelerates
blood flow.
Sometimes the blood comes out as gel,
which is weird.
It's supposed to,
but there's what,
I didn't know his lot it cause I posted
a video of it while they were doing it.
A lot of people are saying that cuppings
bad for you.
And then I did research.
There is,
if it goes bad,
it goes bad.
It leaves permanent damage if they,
if they don't do it right.
And really,
yeah,
if there's some photos that are pretty
disturbing where like pretty much just
holes in people's backs.
Oh fuck yeah.
But yet then the Olympians do it,
you know,
like people that people for the Olympics
do it.
So it's like,
what's,
you know,
well I don't know shit about medicine,
but I would imagine,
oh my God,
what is that cup and gone back and he's
man left with horrific holes in back
after botched.
Whoa.
That's awful.
That could be just somebody who did it
completely wrong.
Well.
Well what what,
what?
What's that one?
That far right where it looks like it
horns lower.
Right.
Lower right the bottom.
We'll keep going.
Scroll down,
scroll down.
Scroll down.
That one to the right in the middle with
the orange and the blue,
the right all the way to the right.
Jamie,
the other right edge of the screen.
Go to the
edge of the screen.
Dot Guy.
Bam.
Yeah,
cause he's got horns.
Oh this is a water buffalo horn to being
used for it,
but they're just using buffalo horn.
Says Cups.
Oh,
what copping with buffalo horns.
Look,
Rogan does.
So Yo Bro,
I do that based on my balls,
my nig route.
What made sense to me is that you would
kind of like create damage,
which is while that blood exists and
that maybe that it'd be like almost like
a prp sort of a thing where all that
extra blood that you've created from
that area would go and help the blood
flow to the part that's injured and they
accelerate healing.
He never know man,
because it's,
you can't say that people that are in
the Olympics don't ever do anything
stupid cause they definitely would do
something stupid.
Someone can talk to him in and doing a
bunch of shit if he,
if sometimes like the psychological edge
and believing that there's something
that's going to work really good,
we'll be just enough to get a few people
to do it.
But this has been around for a while.
This has been around long enough where
people are going like,
you know there's like really significant
benefits things real.
They really do it that way.
Yeah.
It's almost like traditional for I guess
Korean culture because I mean they were
just doing it like it was nothing.
I had a family dinner.
That's crazy.
But maybe that works,
you know?
I mean the only way you find out of
stuff like this works,
which is like a really unconventional
therapy is you've got to try it.
If all those super genius type guys that
are training these Olympic athletes and
getting them to peak performance and
what could potentially be worth millions
and millions of dollars in sponsorship
money if they win the gold medal,
if they're having these people get all
cupped up is probably something to it
kept up right in this day and age.
I think it's like acupuncture.
I feel like I don't know enough to know
if that's accurate or not.
It seems like it is.
Some people believe in it a lot cause
they pay a lot of money for it.
Do it all the time.
Yeah,
for sure.
Um,
a lot of people do believe in
acupuncture,
but copping seems to me to be like more
next level.
It's like you're pulling the skin away
from the area to the point where it
bleeds and turns into the big ass
bruise.
They have this giant circle red spot
where the increased blood flow hasn't
been filtered out of the body.
Yeah.
Like you got some weird shit happened
there.
That ain't normal thing.
You got a big circle bruise on your
back,
right where you're hurt.
Oh,
I see what you're doing.
You're making it all bleed in there so
it flows everything out of there and
heals it up quicker.
It kind of makes sense to a dummy like
me,
like I don't know anything about how the
actual body functions in terms of like
how things heal and whether or not it
would accelerate or not,
but that Michael Phelps guys doing it.
Yeah.
When I asked him how has it feel
afterwards,
he says it took a refreshing,
I feel way energetic now and relaxed.
Well it's like people that wanted to
deny the benefits of cryotherapy before
like some papers came out.
There's a lot of people poopooing and
partly for good reason.
It's cause a lot of the people that were
running these cryotherapy sites got
overzealous in their claims.
They got real overzealous in their
claims of like how much weight you can
lose,
how much better you can look,
all these different things that may or
may not be true when it comes to throw
cryotherapy,
especially in the way they described it,
but what can't be denied is the way it
makes you feel.
It makes you feel fucking amazing.
You do three minutes.
And while that was crappy prior therapy
places you come out of there like,
whoa,
everybody I know that's tried has been
like,
whoa.
Like I,
I'll give a lot for that.
Woo.
Like that was good,
but everybody's right to be suspicious
because the part before the world was
annoying.
There was like a lot I like,
you know,
like in [inaudible] college in your skin
and it's like a virtual face lift and
like there's a lot of people are
claiming some night,
where's this?
You gotta you gotta be able to prove
that,
but they can prove anti inflammatory
markers in the blood.
They can prove all these like,
um,
hormones and these,
neurochemicals that your brain can,
can make when you're a,
you're in that tank when a cryotherapy
chamber rather,
you done it yet.
Now I want to do it today and now.
Still be good to get you to do it today.
Yeah,
maybe I would ever see.
I'll definitely do it.
I just,
today I don't,
I don't feel great.
Don't be a poser.
May make you feel better.
I hate it.
Hate it.
I had a milkshake last night and I have
two minutes in there.
Woke up at six in the morning.
This is the whole podcast has been a
ruse to get me to get you into the
cryotherapy chamber.
I don't want to do a couple of sesh
youtube.
This youtube,
someone's going to burn.
You'll touch the wall.
Test the laws,
but people do go in as couples,
but you gotta be like right close to
each other.
Yeah.
People like to endorse it together.
Tom Air.
Do you have a tank here now though?
Yes,
we do.
That's cool.
Yes.
We did a crash crash.
Made it float lab.
Shout out to the float lab.
Float lab.
Dennis Westwood.
Yeah.
Crashed.
Put it in there.
He's a wizard.
He knows how to do it.
It's all crazy.
Filter ozone and UV light filters.
One Micron field.
He was explaining it all to me.
It was like,
it sounds good.
It sounds like you did good shit.
I'm too fucking dumb.
Plus I can't pay attention to
everything.
That's a problem,
man.
That's how I feel when people keep
bringing up bitcoin.
I was like,
let me know.
Let me know when you get this sorted
out.
Because I watched a lot of,
uh,
a lot of things.
I can't follow the bitcoin show.
I can't,
I just,
I can't.
So when we got those bitcoins,
man,
when I,
when he gave us bitcoin's a long time
ago,
who gave us a bit of,
uh,
Andrea plus,
right?
I've been trying to open up my wallet or
find my password to that wallet.
It's gone.
Like,
I,
I'll never be able to get that bit coin
he gave him,
even though it was only at the
University of it.
Let it be a statistical anomaly.
It's probably worth of dollars,
billions,
billions for now.
It's like you get in and get out and
people are accusing people of pump and
dumps and there's subterfuge.
Subterfuge is taken into consideration
of some of the highs and the lows
anyway,
of course.
Just like everything,
right?
Like big corporations taking over shit.
It's like these,
uh,
these patterns are not normal.
They're normal.
You see them coming.
If you're going to have something like
Bitcoin,
you're going to have people for sure.
Not everyone's going to be,
well,
hey man,
I'm a fucking thief.
But now with Bitcoin,
bitcoin would be super cool.
No more deception.
This is about the future.
It's resolution,
it's about resolution.
This is about the children.
Now anybody's a scam artist is going to
be a scam artist and anything they can,
whether it's a re a fake religion or
fake dating site or fucking whatever,
whatever they could do.
Whatever they can get you with,
they're going to get you with like,
oh,
this is what you guys do now.
Okay,
I'll pretend to be that operate in
there.
Right.
What do you think is the next big
breakthrough that's going to change in
terms of like how technology and people
get along?
He's going to be a robot.
Sex Doll.
No,
I think home home,
uh,
assistance,
you know,
like having a robot couldn't be your
home base.
Like computer.
Uh,
I dunno like these Alexis and I'll like
apple's about to release Thurs and
Google has released Thurs and
I seen the autonomous robots that
monitor parking lots now.
Yeah,
I tweeted it I think yesterday,
but definitely robots.
We're going to give up our security and
all our privacy at the same time.
Hmm.
We're going to be fine because the robot
is going to be watching us.
Keep an eye on me.
Robot.
This is going to be zero privacy,
zero.
It's real close.
That's already there.
But I mean real close to not just
regular zero privacy,
but like no one ever has a moment alone
ever.
It doesn't exist anymore.
Like it will slowly erode.
Then you'd go into the mountains in the
put cell phone towers out there and then
it's going to be it.
Whatever the technology is,
it's going to be,
you're going to know where everyone is
at any moment and we're going to really
get to know each other.
What do you got Jamie?
I was looking up for the thing I saw.
I saw,
and it wasn't on your twitter feed.
I guess.
I saw a video of like autonomous parking
robots,
building cars in and out of spots.
I didn't put it on twitter.
I thought it did
shit.
Um,
it was,
uh,
a comp.
Appreciate.
I retweeted it.
You know what it does though.
I think I retweeted somebody else
saying,
hey,
this is happening or something like
that.
So it's probably not that clear.
One of the more recent tweets tapping
and Brian,
they're going to be flying around us
monitoring us.
You saw that
one robot,
I think it was in San Francisco.
Beat up homeless people or something
like that.
Good move.
Yeah.
And stuff like that happens.
There's going to be a big pull back.
It's crazy.
Robots.
Fucking homes.
We need robots picking on the
downtrodden.
That's good move.
Let them know you post.
These are on your way out.
The robots are here.
I mean that literally is like the first
wave of immigrants from the silicone
world.
Robots at fuck with homeless people.
The first,
the first invaders tripping them and
stuff.
I robot.
The thing about I robot as you'd watch
it and it was,
it was made just at the right time.
It was made where you didn't think it's
ever possible.
It's made at a time.
Well this is pretty cool.
Like yeah man.
The future.
Yeah.
I could see it being real.
But you didn't think it was really
possible and now you watch I robot and
you go,
oh,
it's inevitable.
That's inevitable.
That thing that does the robot thing w
pretends to be a person and looks real
freaky.
That's easily doable.
Or we set machinima.
What's that one?
That's it.
Security robots are using two w uh,
are being used to ward off San
Francisco's homeless population.
That's the drug.
What's it called?
Who makes that thing?
Say they retired it.
Oh,
they did.
There's a whole company that makes those
things and has them like wandering
around parking lots and I'm man,
I hope I retweeted it.
I tried to um,
somebody sent it to me and I was like,
okay,
that's how it happens.
They just have these things wandering
around,
recording everything.
So everybody's responsible for any car
accident.
Anything that ever happens if it hears
is someone's screaming rape.
If it hears someone's screening police
and immediately goes to the scene and
films,
there's no worries about its own
mortality.
It's streaming in real time.
It gets to record all altercations
between people.
Eventually hotels agree.
As long as this is password secure and
encrypted,
they allowed to have the fire detector
and the corner double as a video camera
that records everything in the room at
all times.
What's going to happen.
Yeah,
I agree.
Just got to get used to people watching
your fuck and ready.
I took the sticker off my webcam on my
laptop a long time jet go joe.
They can watch me all I want.
I don't know why I'm more nervous about
this in 2018 this is what silly.
I mean it's become accelerated like I,
I'm more nervous every year when it
comes to technology because I'm not
nervous in a,
in a way that I think it's totally 100%
negative but nervous in the way.
Like it just seems to me that we might
be in the middle of something and not be
paying attention like it,
that it's happening so fucking fast that
we're caught up in it and it's just wild
wave of change and I'm just trying to
make sense of it while it's happening.
But then there's something about like
numbers,
like I used to think that saying like
the year 2017 2000 it's a stupid,
who cares what year it is?
It's all just now.
But no,
there's like a way we feel about it
differently.
Like you,
oh,
it's a fucking 2018 dude,
dude.
It's like you have a feeling about you
now.
It's like we're,
we're very,
very far ahead in this game.
This is,
this is the future.
2018 that's a crazy number.
Hey Man,
it's 1979 nope,
it's 2018 whoa.
So weird.
And when does this thing,
like,
if you had to guess,
how much longer does the human race
have?
Six months.
It seems like if you really had to
guess,
we're not going to be here forever.
Right?
So we're not going to be here a hundred
thousand years from now or 200,000
years from now.
We're just not,
I started listening to the audio book of
Sapiens.
Yeah.
And that's,
I feel like that's what it's getting to.
That question you're asking is the first
couple chapters are leading up to like
he says it over and over again like
thousands of years from now,
maybe 2000 is what it's saying that the
human race won't be or human beings
won't be what we are today.
We'll be another evolution of whatever
that is.
Because off of Australia Pickett.
Yeah.
I was trying to pick the guests
Australia pithiness see if you find any
good pictures of that thing.
I mean this is what they think.
They think that that that's what started
it.
That was when it was like fairly
distinctly human.
It's gonna.
It's gonna keep going.
It's going to go to some new thing.
There it is.
Look at that thing.
I mean that's so close.
It's what like a walking upright
chimpanzee and then that got smarter and
that got smarter and things kept going.
But the thing that really fucks you up
is,
it's not that long ago.
I think Australia Pythius was less than
2 million years.
Right?
It sounds right.
And then there's a modern homo sapiens,
which I think they think are somewhere
in the neighborhood of 300 to 500,000
years old.
They keep moving it around a little bit.
When they find some new dead guy,
they find some new bones and they're
like,
oh,
this one's older.
They got to the iconic guessing.
I want to say they're in the
neighborhood of 300,000
that ain't shit,
dude.
That ain't shit.
That just happened.
If that's when they really started.
So you're talking about 300,000
years from now.
Uber.
It's crazy.
We're going to be made out of gas.
We're going to be like those fires that
aren't petroleum.
You won't be able to see us are
intelligent to be all pervasive.
We'll,
we'll have a one operating system that
we share with mother earth.
They'll plug it into,
our brains will plug into the ground and
we'll,
we'll become divine.
How about that?
No,
I don't know.
No one's here.
That's how I am.
Like let him go.
Just go to him.
He'll come back.
Wow.
I always wonder what they thought about
this 200 years ago.
150 years ago,
what they thought are we,
I feel like they thought that the world
is going to end too back then.
Yeah,
but he's always daughters away from an
ending.
Sure.
I mean anytime,
anything,
especially back when there was media,
anytime
anything catastrophic happened in your
area,
you thought that was going to be the
end.
Okay.
And the moon was made as cheese.
It's,
it's really weird how recent that was.
That's what's weird.
When you just think about hundreds of
thousands of years,
it seems like a long ass time,
but it's not.
When you talk,
talk about the shape of human beings and
what what's happened in that amount of
time,
especially in the last few hundred or
few thousand years,
just all you need is sick.
If you want to like really impress the
shit out of people,
give me 10,000
years,
10,000
years ago,
years now you're like,
wow,
you'd freak out.
There's no other time in history.
That would be the case.
Like every other time in history,
10,000
years would be like,
whoa.
They figured out how to make cooler
houses.
Like,
Whoa,
he's riding an elephant.
How do you figure that out?
Like,
Whoa,
all that bone is way better than my bow
and Arrow every 10,000
years,
no big deal.
And then all of a sudden,
one 10,000
year period and you have everything,
you got the pyramids,
you got space travel,
you've got the internet,
you've got video photography,
three d printers.
Every time you say something like this,
this,
uh,
pops in my head,
the end of gangs in New York,
which shows that montage of the hundred
years or so of New York changing.
Nice.
Thinking about how that's only a hundred
years in New York changed from this
crazy nothingness even though it's
really big then to like tons of
skyscrapers and bridges and all of what
it is today.
And it wasn't any,
anything close to that back then.
And that's like what a hundred years?
And you're talking about 10,000
but that's so much more time compared to
a hundred.
Yeah.
That's an amazing montage.
Timelapse,
what would you call that?
That's time lapse.
Look at that.
That's incredible.
Okay.
New York City's a freak out man and even
more crazy look at that keeps going and
that's even bigger now.
Oh my God.
And towers aren't there.
Yeah.
In New York City is a genuine freak out.
Unless you've been,
you should go.
If you've been in,
you get it.
You're like,
yeah,
it's not so love gone,
but if you haven't been,
it's a paradigm shifter because you
realize that it's possible.
It's such a big city.
I've been a lot of big cities,
but New York City is so crazy and it's
the way it's constructed that you go
there,
you have like a different feel about
you.
You're like,
Whoa,
okay.
We're in New York City.
This is,
this is different.
It is different.
These buildings are fucking giant.
These people are everywhere.
This is crazy.
This is,
this is a different,
completely different feeling
and different people.
Yeah.
Unfortunately,
the people are straddled down by the
echoes of the emigrants that were their
great grandparents and their
grandparents and their struggle that
they had to get from Europe over to
America.
This is my thought because this is my
own family.
I'm talking about.
I feel like,
uh,
a lot of the Italian immigrants with my
grandfather,
he came over when was boy and his family
and a on both my mom's and my dad's
side.
They all came over from Europe,
from either from Ireland or from Italy.
And they were all like really aggressive
risk taking people,
you know?
And those are the people that built that
whole area,
which is just all you think about like
what a crazy accomplishment it is to
build this gigantic city from all these
immigrants that came over from Europe,
you know,
from 1700 whatever it is on just
construct and all these incredible
buildings.
So very,
very bizarre accomplishment.
But that same kind of energy,
you know,
that brought those people over there in
the first place would create like a lot
of interpersonal conflict and a lot of
aggression.
I don't know if New York's totally
gotten past that.
I think they have more now than ever
before.
Like they,
I was reading something about the crime
rate that New York's crime rate is
lowest.
It's been in a long ass time.
I think we're at the highest right now.
Right?
La Is he making this sub?
I feel like I just saw something the
other day where if I had more homicides
this year,
then recent,
you fall asleep.
It seems like it.
I'm not trying to remember.
I think I saw something that was close
to that,
but I thought the murder rate was down,
but violent crime was up here.
Let me just,
we have a police chase.
More pimps lapse in ever three police
chases is a day on the TV.
It's like ridiculous.
How
that's awesome.
Yeah.
A police chase their fucking terrifying
cause you don't want the cops just let
someone run away or you don't want the
cops to slam into you or they're chasing
some guy,
you know close.
Yeah.
Crime rates in New York City reached
record lows as a article about it.
The blasio.
That's the guy,
right.
It's just if you don't know that that's
possible.
Going there and seeing that it's
possible and then realize that its home
within a hundred years,
that's where it's mind boggling or 200
years or whatever in New York Syndrome
has been around for in totality.
Okay.
What is the world we're experiencing
right now going to be like in a hundred
years?
I mean are
okay.
It's,
it almost seems to me like there's no
way we're going to be able to guess.
If you look at how quick that
accelerated and use that as a pattern.
Like that kind of happened all across
the country.
We Chicago,
La,
San Francisco,
they all were nothing and then
everything,
you know
say New York won't be here in a hundred
years because of the water rising up.
Right.
That would be crazy.
Fuck fuck.
Well we have a water crisis and a lot of
parts of the country just got to suck
the water out of the ocean and use it to
spray all these dry ass bushes.
So we stop the fires.
Yo mother thinking I'm always thinking
suck the water out of the ocean.
Stop.
Look,
stop making new houses for a while and
start concentrating on sucking the water
out of the ocean to put out the fire.
Just water.
All those trees.
Dick,
suck out the water out of the air.
Like he could just get a bunch of
humidifiers and then spray the water.
That's not good because then people
would dry out and then the botox goes
up.
This is what I think.
They got to figure out how to the salt
out of the water.
Right?
They know how to do it,
but you can't just take ocean water and
[inaudible] like spray it on your lawn.
Right.
Kill Your fucking lawn.
Well on it.
I don't know about that.
It's fake lawn.
I don't know.
Then nobody,
I mean if if you have crops in your
backyard,
say say if you're growing tomatoes and
you decide to water it with ocean water,
would that be a bad idea?
Yes,
it would.
Assault would be terrible for it,
right?
What is that?
It would just assault would stay,
would kill anything else or just see
red.
It's like,
I don't think that's exactly what rest
is,
but it turn into some sort of fucked up
chemical compound that isn't grass well
hard water.
It kind of poison it.
It'd be a higher salt content than the
uh,
the plant wants to exist on.
And I think that would be the case with
a lot of stuff that doesn't live in the
ocean.
Right.
So you'd have to figure out a way to get
that salt out.
But once you did that water be super
valuable.
Like we're always low on water just,
and we have too much of it now.
It starts sucking out of the ocean.
Just use our own need to like we have a,
a crazy need to use stuff,
you know,
a constant need.
We have a constant need for consumption.
So let's consume the water in the ocean,
suck it out.
They,
they,
they do it.
It's just very expensive and it's like
they do it in San Diego.
I think there's a salt water plant or
something.
But yeah,
we just got to get better at that.
Better process for it.
Yeah.
See everybody is concentrating.
All the money is in robot fuck doll.
So not spending any time working on this
water
problem must get on top of that,
bro.
You got to figure this out,
Ilan.
It can be done and cancer to cancer
first.
I think cancer can be severely medicated
in some circumstances by diet.
And I think that's the thing to
concentrate on first before a pill.
Brian,
that's probably crispr.
Crispr.
Imagine if there was a way you could
just eat shit all day and be jacked.
They Jeremiah Walking boot,
no,
port Jeremiah.
Don't even say that.
30 pounds.
Well,
let's explain to everybody what you're
talking about,
John.
So we do that kill Tony Show and
Jeremiah Watkins and Tony Hinchcliffe
kind of copied like,
you know,
I like the Toms digger formula,
but backwards to see how much weight
they can gain in a month.
Tony did the like working out and trying
to gain muscle weight,
uh,
where Jeremiah just ate like shit for 30
days and gain 30 pounds in 30 days where
Tony only gained 2.5
pounds,
I think it was.
Yeah.
It was just over three pounds.
30 pounds to Tony Hinchcliffe who gained
just over three pounds.
Jeremiah one nugget.
The hose killed Tony Show and keep his
hair.
Yeah,
the bullshit was in the bed though.
And one of the most funniest nights I've
had in a long time was you calling out
Tony about how it's not fair if Jeremiah
loss,
he had to shave his head.
Well,
this is what I said.
I said,
why this is not an even bet.
Like you guys should both be betting the
same thing.
Like if Jeremiah wins,
all he does is get to sit down in a seat
for like a day.
He gets a hosted,
an episode of the podcast,
he gets to sit in a seat.
So everybody knows it's funny,
but if he won or if you want,
he has to shave his fucking head.
Like that's crazy.
And Jeremiah has nice long hair where
Tony has really short hair would have
grown back in like a day.
Jeremiah,
his hair seems like kind of a part of
who he is.
Like just get silly hair.
It's just big silly fella.
And,
uh,
he likes his haircut.
It just,
but he was willing to do it and I told
Tony,
I was like,
fuck that.
I go,
look dude,
you got to,
you guys have to have the same bet.
I go,
why are you scared to shave your head?
It'd be amazing.
I go,
how about this?
How about even better?
You don't have to shave your head.
You have to wear lipstick on stage for a
year.
Tony said that.
What did it Tony Bring it up.
You're like,
hey joe.
Joe was my joke.
You don't remember what I did.
I said it.
And then after I was trying to force him
into doing,
cause he didn't want to do it.
I go,
you know what's fucked up?
It was Tony's idea and I just threw him
under the bridge.
I was like,
I don't know why you want to wear
lipstick,
man.
This is weird.
Oh my God.
That he really did.
No,
no,
no.
Do you remember I was saying that
everybody was dying laughing.
The reason why everybody was dying
laughing because they knew I was just
fucking with them.
I was like,
it was his idea,
which was so weird.
No,
but the idea was you would have to go on
stage and then once you're on stage you
have to put lipstick on or we would
decide that you,
uh,
had to have it on when you walked out to
the crowd either or.
We didn't decide.
And then you could take it off after 15
minutes.
So if you were doing like a headline of
set somewhere and he'd do an an hour for
the first 15 minutes,
you're wearing makeup.
So I said,
but here,
the thing about that,
the thing about that beautiful red
lipstick is that it would make you
concentrate on a joke about why the fuck
you were willing to make a bat.
How you lost the bat,
what you know,
and then rationalize,
rationalize away about nothing wrong.
How come?
Chapsticks okay,
but lipstick gain,
you know,
how come girls get the word lipstick,
Bro?
What the fuck are we doing man?
Like what is this?
Dad had been so funny.
If he had to wear lipstick for a year,
it would have been hilarious.
He wouldn't,
it wasn't.
I told them I would do it too.
Yeah.
You got home?
I said I'd do it.
Oh,
so I'll do it too.
Come on.
We'll all do it together.
Don't be scared.
Take it back.
It's not a hard bed.
It's funny.
You'd have to,
you'd have to like have the lipstick
years photos where every time we were on
stage and just what you have,
you have like a,
like a package of wet wipes with you
bring on stage and a dry white towel and
everybody knows you got 15 minutes,
lipstick time.
You might grow to like it,
you know,
he might start getting her nails did and
everything.
You definitely could come up with bits
from it.
It could be possible and it would be fun
for people to,
to like go along with Tony.
Can't handle that.
Johnny scared.
I feel like he's scared.
Right.
I think it should at least shave his
head.
He should've shaved his head.
He should've had a deal.
Obviously he has way more beautiful hair
than I do.
And,
um,
but I feel like if I had good hair and
shave it off cause I knew it would come
back.
It's super shit.
Tony has super shirts.
Tony Hinchcliffe man,
that's Eddie Izzard,
Eddie Izzard and lipstick on is Eddie
Izzard.
Um,
living as a woman now somebody told me
that I really,
yeah.
Yep.
Mom,
not necessarily living as a woman.
It's still looks like as Eddie has her
dress with lipstick and a dress.
I Dunno.
Um,
Eddie Izzard we'll have my respect for,
for all his days because Eddie Izzard,
uh,
ran a marathon a day with no training
all around Ireland.
Do you know about that thing?
Dude?
He didn't even prepare for it.
Wow.
He just finished him.
Yes,
he did it all.
Wow.
He wrote up marathon a day for like four
weeks or something crazy.
Right.
Wasn't it dude,
his feet were literally falling apart.
Like they would show them cleaning up
his feet and taking care of his skin.
It was just torn to pieces,
mad.
It was just straight,
raw mental toughness and a resolve that,
I mean,
you think about him,
you think about him as a comedian,
a funny guy,
a thoughtful guy,
and he had that odd thing that he was
doing where he was wearing women's
clothes and all that stuff.
27 marathons in 27 days.
Yeah,
you don't,
you don't really know what that guy's
about until you watch this documentary
that you could watch online.
Um,
what does it,
is there a name for it where people can
search it?
It's amazing,
man.
You'll find it.
So,
um,
what he did was,
I don't,
I don't even remember what the charity
was.
Do you remember what the charity was?
Was some sort of a charity?
If he did the 27 marathons,
I think he only took a couple of days
off,
like they're here and there.
There were days where he literally
couldn't,
couldn't walk.
He like,
he had to,
I feel like he did this twice to Jesus
Christ.
This says he did 43 marathons in 51
days.
Oh my God.
Oh my.
That might be the new thing.
He did it again.
I bet it was a marathon.
Man Doesn't show 43 marathons in 51
days.
Oh my God.
So he did it before.
He did less and then he came back and
did it again.
Wow.
Somebody told me about it a few years
ago,
but it was after the fact.
I didn't know he's done it twice kinds
of fucking animal.
It's crazy.
He's an animal.
I mean,
that's just crazy.
But then I read something,
um,
unrelated.
I read something that he,
uh,
was living as a woman,
but that might not be real.
Hmm.
He might just feel like we're in a dress
that day.
He said he answered,
you run 53 marathons,
whatever the fuck he did.
You can do whatever you want.
Dude.
Maybe his dick fell off this in 2016 and
then the first one was in 2009.
Ah,
okay.
That makes sense.
Because the 2009 one I think I found out
about
around 2012 or something like that,
I remember watching it,
thinking that's,
that's a kind of mental toughness that
very few people have.
I don't think I have it to run that many
marathons.
And how many days you might have to
force yourself into that too.
In the last day,
Jesus Christ,
what?
He ran a double marathon on the last
day.
So that was the toughest day of my life.
Holy Shit,
dude.
If I've had to take off to go to the
hospital,
so we had to make up one.
Oh my God.
He had to go to the hospital to get his
kidneys checked out.
So on day 27 I ran my 26 and my 27th
marathon double marathon on the last
day.
So that was the toughest day of my life.
I'm telling you,
man,
that is not a regular person.
A guy who is not like a Cam Haynes type
guy who's in shape,
who could just do like campaigns can run
a marathon a day and it's not hard.
Like if he no bullshit.
If he wanted to go and do 27 marathons
in 27 days,
he'd be like,
yeah,
I've done that already.
He could just do it.
He can go do that.
But,
but Eddie Izzard was not,
he wasn't planning for that.
He liked,
he didn't get in shape before he did it.
Unless he did the second time,
I might be wrong about the second time.
The first time he did it,
he didn't get in shape for it.
And to see him run in those 27
marathons,
it's just like,
it's all just mental toughness.
He just forced his body to keep moving.
What does it say here?
He's going into politics and 20,
20.
Oh Shit.
King of the world.
Eddie Izzard,
he maybe he's the first print
transgender president if he decided to
go for it to be born here and we fix
that well,
president of where they live.
I also did all these marathons in South
Africa where the weather was a bit
hotter than it wouldn't be.
And listen to Dan were music duck and
crocodiles.
Wow.
So he's going to go into a um,
yeah.
He,
his reasoning here,
he says,
that's why I pulled that up.
Wow.
So he's doing these races just to get
people to pay attention to the messages
behind.
He's not really into racing.
That's interesting.
Wow.
Interesting.
He's a very thoughtful guy and,
but what impressed me the most is not
just like the words that he strings
together and how he says things,
which is always impressive,
but someone who can do that,
like that is not normal.
That's extraordinary because he's,
he's,
it would be extraordinary for someone
who's in great shape,
like a person who is like a um,
you know,
world class like that Courtney Dole,
Walter Lady,
if she ran 27 marathons in 27 days,
it would still be remarkably impressive.
It is just the amount of time that you
have to spend running every day for 27
days.
That shit is impressive.
That's just impressive.
But
to do it when you're just a guy who's a
comic and did not even in shape,
he wasn't even,
he wasn't even thin.
You have like,
like a bit of a belly,
but he wasn't lean by any stretch of the
imagination.
It didn't look like a runner.
Does he still do comedy?
I don't know man.
I feel like I haven't seen or heard
about him in a long time.
I think we'll,
we're guilty over here of not paying
attention to what happens in comedy
anywhere else in the world.
You know,
I,
I had somebody has to like beat me over
the head with somebody that's really
funny from somewhere else for me to pay
attention.
I just saw that they have roast battle
now and in UK.
Here he goes,
Eddie izzard believe me tour.
Not that it matters,
but find out if he's a woman.
She in French.
Whoa.
Of course he's a genius.
Fuck guys doing shows in French.
The show was in French.
Just shows in French.
It's sows.
Fuck man.
I'm gonna go there with those Google
Pixel headsets.
It's all he stuff.
Yeah,
man.
That's,
that's where,
uh,
originally I got the idea of us being
able to communicate with plants.
I figured this is step one.
Step one is the Google Pixel earbuds.
It let you listen to someone speak
Spanish and real time translate it to
English.
Step two is they figure out some sort of
a universal code that the plant world is
willing to accept and we start
communicating back and forth to the
plant world.
Step three,
they develop a headset,
some sort of a neural interface with a
human being.
When they put this thing on and you go
out into the forest and you communicate
with the trees,
that's frequency.
I say that hundred percent.
Why Not Joe?
I have to do is get them to obviously
communicating with themselves.
There's some form of communication
between plants.
This has been proven cause a bunch of
weird shit they do.
Like they changed the way they taste
based on whether or not they hear things
going on in the distance that he or
someone eating them in the distance and
they'll change the way they taste.
They catch things down wind like the
smell of them getting consumed by
another animal will change the way they
test.
Like that was the case.
What the,
uh,
Keisha Bush and giraffes,
they found that giraffes that we're
eating these Acacia Bushes,
uh,
upwind.
Upwind when it's downwind,
yeah,
down upwind.
When they would eat them,
the smell of them consuming them would
come down when and it would change the
flavor profile of all these other trees.
They would turn nasty tasting to avoid
the giraffes from eating them.
Hmm.
That's crazy dude.
So then,
then they figured out that they could
play the sound of caterpillars munching
leaves right next to the tree and it
would have the same effect.
Wow.
Yeah.
So
somehow or another,
they know what it sounds like when
they're eating.
I don't know if they try everything like
we're going to have sex with this tree
and just see what happens or vertical.
The tree vegans are super not happy
about plants being alive and thinking
you bring it up,
they get so triggered.
It is one of the most triggering things.
His plant intelligence research they
cause they want to claim moral
superiority.
They want to claim that,
you know La,
la,
I can't hear the plant.
There's that cabbage is screaming when
you pull it out of the ground,
you fuck screaming for its family.
The interconnectedness with the mycelium
and the soil just beautiful.
Yeah,
that,
but I think what's going to fix veganism
honestly is that a robot meet that that
artificial lab created meat.
I was going to fix it.
People are gonna realize like,
Yo all just healthier this way he body
has more vitality.
It's going to be extinct,
veganism is going to be extinct in the
future.
As soon as they come up with super
ethical meat,
there's going to be no reason for it.
Everybody's going to go watch too.
And I feel so much better when I eat
steak.
It's just fuck like it's,
it's,
there's obviously a reason why we're
having all this debate.
It's not like it's crystal clear one way
or another.
It's like it's not good that an animal
die so that you'll live.
That's not good.
That doesn't feel good,
but it's not good if they get over
populated either.
Again,
that's not good either.
You know,
it was what I was reading this thing
about,
um,
there's an animal called an hour dad.
It's like a sheep.
And um,
they,
uh,
imported them to Texas a long time ago
and they don't taste good to eat
apparently.
Or maybe a lot of people were eating in
the wrong way.
So because of that,
they don't hunt them a lot.
Or if they do hunt them,
it's not like the same way they hunt
whitetail deer or something like that.
And they live in these like difficult to
get to remote parts of like West Texas
and shit.
And so then some of them,
the ranchers have taken to like firing
guns out of helicopters to get rid of
him.
Like this is crazy.
Like you have animals that you're,
you're hunting with helicopters that you
brought over here from another place,
but they look like,
just like they're cool looking man.
They look like some sort of a star wars
type
goat creature,
sheep creature.
They have the amazing horns.
There was enormous horns,
but apparently they just can't figure
out a way to make them taste good.
This is from everybody that I know
that's tried to eat them,
give it to an Asian now,
figure it out.
It's probably a good call.
I wonder if there must be somebody that
thinks they taste good and knows the
dude,
but pull up a picture of an hour.
Dad,
sheep.
It's like,
will you look for,
I haven't.
I'll Wafi sheep.
No,
no.
It's like,
it's called Aoudad.
They're like one of the few animals that
are like universally thought to tastes
like shit.
Wow.
From people that hunt them,
but they're here and they have to
control their population.
So what do you do about them?
What do you do about wild pigs?
We did do about animals to get to the,
unless you want to let predators loose.
That's it right there.
That picture.
Oh,
that's a stone sheep.
No,
I'm,
it's our dad.
It's like,
how'd you spell it out of you a dad?
I only have a picture of those fuckers.
Um,
Aoudad Hunt Texas,
but type in that because they're very
popular to hunting in Texas,
but I don't think a lot of people will.
Our debt hunt Texas.
Yeah,
those are um,
dear.
That's not the same thing about
that.
How do you spell that?
Our Dad word out.
None of these things are the Aoudad.
How would that is like big,
thick,
um,
horns say it to Siri and see what she
comes up with?
Well,
either way I'll find it.
Um,
what,
what would you do with all the,
if we did figure out a way to never have
an animal suffer again,
but we could all eat meat,
what would you do with all the animals
that existed?
That would be a giant dilemma.
Like how many people would say,
yeah,
you know what,
that's all well and good,
but I want a cow that just got killed.
I want a real cow.
It's really alive.
It makes me think and feel better.
Would have to add.
Is that it?
No,
that was the closest.
Some else [inaudible] that's some sort
of feral sheep all Parra that's weird
that they don't have Alad Dad.
Maybe try a different spelling.
Aoudad sheep hunt Texas.
Anyway.
Um,
the delicate balance of like prey and
Predator.
Like how do you manage that if you have
certain populations of these animals
just running loose?
Somebody sent me a video.
That's it.
I just took the word off.
It just that she texted.
Go back to that last one you had.
That's exactly what it looks like.
Hmm.
Look at that thing.
It looks like the devil.
Right?
Those horns.
That's like some sate and shit from
Damien.
It's weird that meat is not just meet
that.
Like he can't just like take that leg
off and eat it.
Nope.
It's definitely different.
Some people say a goat is delicious,
but I think it really depends upon the
diet of the goat.
And some goats,
they eat weird shit and they taste
terrible and some,
some goats they eat,
you know,
mmm delicious plants and you eat them.
And I bet it tastes as good as anything
you're ever going to eat.
It really did.
It varies so much between the people
that say it tastes amazing versus the
people that say it tastes terrible.
That's a perfect example of one.
I mean that looks like something from
Star Wars.
Well,
you could say that it's crazy looking,
but what would you do?
So if we did figure out a way to have
all of our meat come out of a
laboratory,
so nothing has to die.
What do we do about all the animals?
Zoo Zoo.
That's not right.
That's even crazier.
Like did not have a ranch instead of a
zoo animal island do.
That's it.
That's the island we were talking about.
We ship all the animals to like some
giant like New Zealand and make a deal
with New Zealand.
We're going to bring home with lions,
Bro,
but with no predators to net deck
drastic park basically.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
You'd have to bring over predators to,
you'd have to create a wild ecosystem.
Just a fully wild ecosystem and just
everybody else.
There's so many people by the year 2099
that we have occupied every single
stretch of the world and everything
looks like New York City except one
continent,
which is like central park for the
world.
So the world is now one enormous city,
but we've maintained like the Amazon,
the Amazon rain forest is what we
cherish.
That's our last connection to mother
earth.
Before we slip in to some symbiotic
relationship with computers,
Don,
we're allowed to visit this island in
little hamster ball.
So yeah,
dude,
just like Jurassic Park,
this could be real.
It could be real.
I mean this literally,
it sounds crazy,
but if you're talking about 500 years
from now,
we literally could have occupied every
single part of the earth except for one
place.
We literally could make some sort of a
deal.
They'll like when nobody goes to the
Amazon,
thinks you'd be a great science fiction
movie.
Feel free to steal it,
steal it,
dark mirror.
I think we need to start building
underwater,
underwater cities that she imagined.
You're underwater.
We'll see a little crack in the wall and
you're coming home and you're on edibles
and you're so tired,
but you have to be at work at three
hours and you look and you see a little,
just a small crack in the world and you
go,
do I talk about this crack I taught?
Maybe it's just a flaw in the glass.
It just looks like a crack and then as
you're,
as you're going back home at the end of
your shift,
it looks just a little bigger.
She,
I'd rather did this and the Mars,
I trust underwater cracks.
Marlon going in a tesla,
the Mars,
just the feeling of all the walls
exploding instantaneously and billions
of gallons of ocean water crushing your
very existence instantaneously.
Sober,
chill,
boom.
Just a smash of the ocean,
hundred feet deep around you crushing
everything.
As soon as that crack gets big enough,
I'm freaking me out.
So you would do Mars?
No,
I want and I'm not doing anyone any of
that.
Fuck themselves.
I even getting submarine.
Nope,
no desire.
I want to see Nimo at Walt Disney
though.
It was a fun rog.
Great for Little Kids Finding Nemo.
You go out in the little submarine and
they have a little show they do for you.
It's wonderful.
That's about as good as it gets.
How about that one lady who was a
reporter who went in the guy submarine
and he killed her and chopped her up to
capitate at her like,
what the fuck he imagine if you're a
lady and you go out there and you're
looking to do a story about a guy who
made his own submarine and then
somewhere along the line he kills you
and chops you up and throws in the
ocean.
You got to think like when you're going
to visit interview a guy who made a
submarine,
there's no way this guy's gonna chop me
up.
That's not going to happen.
He knows that everybody knows I'm going
to visit him.
I kinda believe his excuse a little,
but then I,
you know that where the hatch just
closed on her head.
Yeah,
but you're supposed to tell people that,
you know,
it's supposed to chop her up and throw
in the ocean and pretend nothing
happened to them.
Did you just tell everybody who's a
horrific accident and you feel terrible
and you get punished and fuck man,
poor lady.
11 days to think about it though.
He had 11 days sort of reading it right
now as you guys were saying it,
uh,
her for her torso is found 11 days
later.
Well first he said she died of carbon
monoxide poisoning.
It previously had said the thing hit
her,
hit her head.
It was 150 pound hatch door.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Did you imagine that?
Oh my God,
that makes sense.
Hatch door hitting your head makes
sense.
But either way,
fuck submarines.
Do Fuck submarines.
Right?
Do you have any desire to go bungee
jumping?
Nope.
Good for you.
So I'm scared of heights.
I don't want any of that.
Fuck all that right.
The squirrel suit doesn't sound
terribly.
What?
It sounds kind of fun.
You did the squirrel so I wouldn't do
it.
It sounds fun.
Flashy.
You.
Um,
let me know when you can do that so I
can prepare for your absence forever.
Going to be anytime soon.
Life insurance policy on the stump.
Fucking call you to clock in the
morning.
I'll lit up,
try to get you to jump off the Alps.
But if he ever gets a suit with some
jets on it,
I might be.
What if that goes wrong?
What if that's like the tesla door
handles it one open up.
So come on man,
don't do it man.
You want to parasail anymore?
Yeah,
but hang gliding is,
I've heard of people like getting shot
up in a hang glider 300 feet and just a
little like spout of air that they can't
control and you're fucked on that phone
call that we're crazy.
Yeah.
This is all that for thrills,
for wild thrills and God dammit we're
going to have flying cars though.
That's no the thing they're looking
into,
there's a lot of people that are
seriously considering flying cars right
now.
I think it's a matter of time before
they locked that down.
I think it's going to be automated
pilots or mean driverless cars first in
that technology.
Then flying,
I think you're totally right and I think
they're going to have the same sort of
like lane departure warnings and all the
stuff that like keeps cars from crashing
into each other,
the correct and that people are just
going to say,
well,
as long as they're autonomous,
it actually makes it more efficient to
use the entire three d space and not
have the,
the landscape marred with all these hard
roads.
I haven't been a bummer today have,
I feel like I'm freaking out.
I'm freaking me out.
I don't know why I'm more serious about
this shit heading into 2018 but it just
seems ominous.
Dom,
dom,
dom.
All right.
I gotta pee so bad.
We have to wrap this up.
I've been holding it in.
Yeah.
I drank too much coffee before this one.
It's almost three hours.
Yeah,
almost three hours.
All right.
Brian Redman,
tell everybody where you are and how can
everybody mock Tony Hinchcliffe they can
contact him at Tony Hinchcliffe on
twitter.
Yeah,
that's right.
Give Jeremiah Watkins some love and
we'll be doing his stand up on the spot
show,
uh,
next Tuesday in the belly room.
It's fun.
Show people make shit up.
Jeremiah is an awesome person and your
show with him is a on every Monday
money,
Jeremiah is going to host the next one
and we're bringing killed Tony to
Houston,
February 1st and Dallas the second
Funsho go out there and support much
respect,
much love a red band on twitter and
instagram and all that good stuff.
And uh,
we'll be back really soon,
like in a few minutes with a Jimmy Smith
formerly of Beltour.
He's here now.
Oh Bye.
[inaudible].